Hey everybody,
this episode of the Joe Rogan experience
is brought to you by squarespace.
Squarespace is a website that allows you
to make your own website a professional
website easily,
quickly,
simply,
and you don't even have to pay for it to
try it.
If you go to squarespace.com,
forward slash joe or squarespace.com,
use the,
uh,
the end of the Codeword Joe to save 10
percent off your first purchase.
If you go there,
you can go try out the service,
build your own website,
and then if you decide you like it,
then add credit card information.
They do that because they're very
confident in what they're making.
It's a,
it's an excellent way to build a
website.
You could build killer websites on your
own with real simple drag and drop
interface.
They offer 24 slash seven support and
they've also launched a logo creator.
You can create a clean,
simple,
custom logo designed for yourself in
minutes.
If you want to check that out.
Go to squarespace.com,
forward slash logo.
They've also launched a new website that
will deliver better customer experience.
They have it set up so that you can
easily start your own store online.
If you are a musician,
you can sell digital music.
If you're a comedian,
If you're a guy who's so fucking
interesting that you can talk and people
want to hear you talk,
you could sell that shit too.
I don't,
I don't recommend it.
Most people are not going to buy it,
but if you do have it,
squarespace can provide it.
That's an awesome way for a Milan like
you or me to make their own website
easily.
This is a very unique time because there
really was nothing like this in the
past.
Used to have to use programs and it was
a pain in the ass to learn.
You have to really dedicate yourself.
So much so that I'd never even attempted
to design my own website,
but I would absolutely make my own
website.
With squarespace,
it's easy.
You can use your own images.
You could set it up in a variety of
different ways.
There's several different patterns and
um,
I've met the people that run it and
they're fucking cool.
So go there,
squarespace.com
and use the code word Joe to save 10
percent off your first purchase and for
a free trial.
So go to squarespace.com
and use the code word Joe were also
brought to you by [inaudible] dot com.
That's o n n I t a human optimization
website.
We're going to have to get some on it to
chrome.
Gracie because he's here and he wants to
get on it.
What do we have it on it?
We have all sorts of nutritional
products,
things like earth grown nutrients,
which is a blend of superfoods,
antioxidants,
Greens,
like wheat grass,
barley,
grass grass,
Kale,
kelp,
all sorts of different healthy Greens,
fill of micronutrients that you might
not get in your everyday diet that you
can add to your diet,
which can help you.
You just balance out your nutrition.
You know,
people are busy.
It's hard to eat totally and completely
healthy all the time.
Uh,
we want to provide you at,
on it with all the keys and all the
tools for you to function at your best,
whether it's nutritional supplements or
whether it's strength and conditioning
equipment like kettlebells,
battle ropes,
a weight vest,
steel,
maces,
ab wheels,
all that shit.
We have the excellent kettlebell cardio
extreme workout videos by Keith Weber.
We sell those.
We sell defense soap,
which is very important if you're into
Jujitsu or wrestling or anything when
your,
your skin comes in contact with funk
defense soap,
uh,
allows your body to maintain its healthy
flora,
but a washes off all the bad bacteria.
And it's made by my friend,
Guy Soco who's a cool dude and a big
supporter of wrestling guy actually just
sent me an email today.
So I want to wish his son well because
his son is competing in the NCAA
wrestling championships at a 145 pounds.
So Gus,
good luck.
Gus Soco.
Alright.
Uh,
use the code word Rogan and save 10
percent on any and all
supplements@onnit.com.
We're here with chrome,
gracie and we're going to get popping
experience
podcast.
So a few years back,
my friend Gordon has to,
who's a,
a guy that I met on the Internet,
said,
Hey,
do you want to have dinner with Hixon
Gracie?
So I said,
fuck yeah man,
if you are a Jujitsu practitioner,
um,
there's,
it's very rare in a sport.
I guess there's a few sports,
like if you think bike racing,
you think,
you think Lance Armstrong,
unfortunately now,
but that's the name,
but the universal name that gets thrown
about in Jujitsu,
there's the last name,
which is gracie.
And then once you get to know Jujitsu
and you understand Jujitsu and you get,
you start training,
everybody always wants to know who's the
best,
who's the best,
who's the best universally regarded as
the all time best is your father,
your father,
Hicks,
and Gracie.
This is not much debate amongst Jujitsu
people.
There's debate as to who's the best
right now.
But I talked to Henzel about this one
time and uh,
and Enzo just shook his head and he
goes,
he's a motherfucker.
It goes,
His is laughing.
It's like he's the best.
He's the best.
And when a guy like henslow's says
something,
I just listened,
you know,
so what is it?
That's when I met you,
you're,
you were with your dad.
And we went and had some dinner and then
we went back to your house and we
watched some fights,
which was amazing to have your dad break
down what,
what guys are doing wrong and what's
wrong with their positioning,
what's wrong with their approach and
what his approach is.
And for me as a student of martial arts
and as a fan of martial arts,
it was a huge honor,
you know,
and you were like 16 or 17 back then.
Yeah.
Something like that that you were into
rap music and all kinds of different
shit.
And so from that,
um,
you know,
I've,
I've run into a few times over the years
when,
when hoists fought Matt Hughes and a
couple other times you've become
yourself,
like one of the most prominent Jujitsu
fighters in the world today.
Um,
and that's so cool to see.
It's so cool to see a young kid with
aspirations and then put in the work.
And it's also cool to see the son of a
great man become a great man himself,
which is very difficult and it doesn't
really happen that often.
You know,
a lot of times the sign of a great man
lives in the shadow of his father and
sort of fall short.
But,
uh,
you and your young life,
you're 25 now,
25 and your young life,
you've already carved out a great name
in Jujitsu with your own
accomplishments.
You're widely considered to be amongst
the very best in the world at Jujitsu.
And how does that feel?
It feels great,
you know,
now finally,
after so long of,
you know,
because I knew when I was a little kid
that I was going to have to be a fighter
or be a martial artist and have to,
you have to really be as much as my dad
wants to make it feel like he didn't put
pressure on me.
And,
and you know,
he did.
You know,
people say he teaches invisible Jujitsu.
Well,
I'll talk about invisible pressure,
you know,
like,
yeah,
like at an early age when first when I'm
a little kid,
I can kind of always see,
you know,
how much my dad trains and how much he,
how big he is a part of what he does in
the world and how much people respect
him and how much recognition you get.
So from a very early age,
you know,
you want to replicate that and you want
to do,
you know,
what your father does if it feels like
cool to you.
And it's always been really cool to me.
Of course when I was a younger up until
like 12 years old,
I used to skate a lot in Jujitsu is kind
of whatever.
But I knew that in the future that that
was what I was going to have to do no
matter what.
So,
you know,
it came to a point where I kind of put
skateboarding aside and uh,
I had gotten hurt skateboarding a bunch
of times and I was like,
you know what,
I don't,
I don't care about skateboarding as much
as I do Jujitsu.
I'm not going to be as good as a
skateboarder as I can be with to which
this kind of all clicked for me a one
day with my brother,
you know,
we,
we were talking and everything and this
was like one of the last conversations
we had and,
and he was always like,
you know,
you could,
whatever you do in life,
you do it one percent,
you know,
you,
you do it the best you can do it.
You know,
if you're going to be a dentist,
you'd be the best dentist.
If you can be a skateboarder,
you'd be the best skateboarder.
But the only difference is right here,
you have an opportunity to do Jujitsu
and you have the best road.
You have the best dad.
As a coach.
You have the best at all,
the tools you need to really be the best
you can be.
And it would be stupid for you not to
really take advantage of this.
And that kind of happened when I was 12.
And um,
after my brother passed I kind of
really,
really put effort into that and I kind
of really made it my mission to make him
proud and to make my dad proud and I
kind of knew what I had in my hands and,
but at that age you never know how good
you're going to get and you never know
what's gonna happen.
So I just kind of dedicated myself,
dedicated myself.
And then,
you know,
when,
when we met each other I was still fully
dedicated but I still hadn't achieved,
um,
you know,
anything really.
And I think like with the,
with,
for me,
like in life when you,
when you,
when you try,
when you try is you only get what you
think you're going to get way later.
You know,
like I put so much dedication into it by
16 years old.
But I hadn't seen any of the,
of the fruits and I hadn't seen any,
any necessarily like big reward from it,
you know.
So it was basically just the passion of
being able to train Jujitsu and being
able to,
to do what I knew was my mission.
And
um,
I kind of lost my track a little bit of
what I was going to say,
but,
uh,
so basically from,
from that age,
you know,
it was,
it was always like I knew that I had to
do that,
you know,
as much as,
as much as things would always.
Like there's always little things that
go in your head that you might want to
like change your or whatever.
But in my mind it was never an option
not to,
to do Jujitsu and never an option not to
be the best I can be and to be the best
in the world.
That was always like where I was going
to be.
I never had a plan b.
I never had a,
Oh,
I was just going to try this and then if
this doesn't work out,
I'd never had that from you.
As always,
this was where I put my energy.
And so I kind of just put my energy into
it.
And um,
you know,
from a very early age,
from 12,
13,
14,
everybody knew me as crone Hixson Hixson
zone or you're hitting.
So I already kind of hated that.
I hated being called Hixon son.
I hate it being called Hawkins over.
I hated being called somebody that I
wasn't,
you know,
and like being recognized for something
that I didn't do somebody other than who
you are.
Yeah.
So I kind of always knew that if I
wanted to to climb out of this name and
climb out of the shadow,
I would have to work twice as hard.
And it was,
it was going to be a real obstacle for
me to get past this.
And that's what I,
in my mind,
that was my ending goal no matter what I
want it to be my own man.
I wanted to be able to represent myself
and my family and everything and I
wanted to be able to be remembered as
somebody who kept it going,
kept the legacy going.
For folks who don't have any experience
in martial arts,
I'll try to explain this to people.
There's,
when you really stop and think about the
history of martial arts,
there's the most important moment,
in my opinion of modern martial arts was
hoists gracie entering into the UFC in
1993 when hoists gracie entered into the
UFC,
we saw for the first time in a real
application,
we saw what we had always wanted to see
in the movies.
A smaller man with technique defeating
larger men,
a smaller man.
You're utilizing leverage in utilizing
his skills to defeat everybody in front
of them.
And from that we got introduced to the
name Gracie.
We got introduced to your father.
We got introduced to Leo,
your grandfather,
who was the most important figure in all
of martial arts.
For folks who don't know martial arts
for the longest time,
for thousands of years,
there was all this debate about what was
the best style,
whether it was a karate or whether it
was Kung Fu.
There was all these different people
that swore that their master could
defeat a thousand men and unarmed
combat.
No one knew what the real deal was until
the UFC came along and that was when the
world got introduced to the name Gracie.
What is it like growing up in that
environment and when did you realize
that your family was different than
everybody else?
I mean,
you come from the most important family
in the history of martial arts.
Martial arts is what every man wants to
be able to do.
Every man wants to be able to find
himself.
Every man wants to be able to kick ass.
The most important family,
in my opinion,
is the Gracie family.
There's no comparison.
Yeah,
I mean you don't really,
you don't really think about it like
that when you're in the gracie family,
you kind of just born into this thing
where it's all about martial arts and
it's all about dedication and discipline
and you come from,
you know,
tradition.
So you don't really think about from the
outside point of view.
You know,
for me it's just been a very normal
thing to train Jujitsu in the living
room to talk about how to defend
yourself,
to talk about,
you know,
the average and health and all this.
This is just very normal for me.
It was never knew.
He seen somebody get in a fight.
It's more interesting than it is.
Like Oh,
a shock.
So it's never been nothing big.
But you know,
the older I get the more I kind of
realized how big what I'm a part of and
how important it is and that only
motivates me more to really step up and
be able to keep this going because,
you know,
my grandfather was a,
was a crazy dude,
you know,
he would challenge anybody and his goal
was to represent just to,
and to prove g two is the best and that
guy weighed 135 pounds and he was not a
physically fit dude.
And you know,
it goes to show how powerful his spirit
was.
And,
and what he did,
he changed the world.
You know,
he,
he made it so that a weak person could
defeat a bigger opponent and you know,
with my dad,
with him leading everything and taking
charge and trying to spread,
you know,
he was a very,
very important person in all of our
lives.
You know,
he made it possible for,
for a weak person to be able to defeat a
bigger opponent to,
you know,
have the self confidence to believe in
something other than physical form.
You have to believe in the leverage.
And,
and he,
you know,
he,
his theory and his,
what he put onto his children is what
gave not only the leverage and the
technique,
but also put physical abilities on top
of it.
So my dad got all the theory of the
leverage and being a weak person and how
to survive if you're weaker.
But my dad wasn't.
He wasn't weak.
He was strong.
So he used the technique and the
leverage and the strength on top of it,
which created a monster.
You know,
he created,
you know,
somebody who is physically strong but
trains like as if he was a very
lightweight of not a physically strong
person.
So he's able to really maximize his
potential and me coming up into this,
you know,
again,
like it's always just been a fun thing
and something to be a part of and it
only kind of really clicked that,
that,
you know,
the older you get,
the more we realize how part of it.
And sometimes I kind of look outside of
myself and I kind of take,
man,
I'm in a,
this is crazy,
you know,
this is like a movie,
like my grandfather was this legend and
my dad is this legend.
And,
and you know,
like I'm the only son and,
it's like a movie,
like an hour.
Not only am I the only son,
but I'm also being able to be able to
prove that I did still in the genes and
it's still a powerful thing that we're
dealing with.
So I,
I,
I'm overwhelmed sometimes.
I kind of looked back and I very
grateful for the situation and obviously
God put,
put me in this situation and put us in
the situation for a reason.
Now I'm most recently you won the
Abudabi submission championships,
which in the world of grappling is the
most prestigious Nogi submission title
in the world.
And for folks no gooey,
there's two different types of Jujitsu,
Jujitsu with the Kimono,
you know,
the,
it looks like a judo uniform,
that's the g,
and then there's Jujitsu with no gate,
which is a much like wrestling or the
type of techniques that you would see in
the UFC because they're not grabbing
clothes very different,
very different.
And as far as,
uh,
the,
the pace of things,
but Abu Dhabi's the,
this,
the most prestigious championship in the
world.
So you accomplished like you hit the top
of the mountain,
you know,
you,
uh,
you became much like the others in the
Gracie family before you became a
champion.
What,
what was that feeling like?
It's a great feeling,
you know,
it's just no complaints about that.
Um,
and you know,
I think this,
in my perfect world,
in my dream,
if you would've asked me if I would have
wanted the Abu Dhabi,
I would have said,
of course I would have wanted it
probably much more times by this age if
you would ask me when I was 15 years
old.
But,
you know,
in life it's not so easy,
you know.
And,
and for me in my life,
everything was easy,
you know,
purple belt was easy,
Brown belt was easy,
so I never had had this obstacle of
challenges and I never really had to dig
deep and figure out what,
what,
what is,
what am I about really?
So my first one,
everything was undefeated as a purple
and brown belt.
And then my first match has a black
belt.
I lost,
I got my ass whooped and it was a mix of
a bunch of things that I came to my
conclusion of why that happened.
But in the end I think that I was just
not mentally ready for that.
And I let all these outside things
affect me.
And anyways,
I lost the fight and really dug deep to
see what I was going to do with my life
and,
and you know,
after you,
you realize what happens and how you can
prevent it and how you going to get
better.
Then you start to really work hard for
what you want to get in.
And I,
after that moment I kind of started to
really become a man and really
understand sacrifice and how to work
hard.
And if you want something in life,
you can't depend on anybody for it and
you can't ask anybody for it.
You have to go in and really work hard
to get it in.
And that I think I started to really
become a man as a black belt.
And that's when I really put my energy
into it.
And you know,
I've,
I've lost tournaments,
I've won lots of tournaments and
sometimes I lose because of points.
And I,
I've never really been about points.
But,
um,
ultimately I feel like now after so long
of being on this journey of this hard
path,
I finally kind of started to find myself
in the past couple of years and I'm
finally getting a,
getting the results that I've,
I've wanted a long time ago and I
realized a lot more about life and about
myself then then if I would have just
won everything.
So that's a great situation to be in.
And um,
I work really hard for this first place,
a metal.
So it's gonna be hard for somebody to
take it from me.
That is an interesting thing,
isn't it?
That you need defeat in order to really
inspire you to the greatness inside of
you.
You need to feel adversity to rise to
the occasion.
Of course you fought was Sergio Moron
who's a very,
very good black belt and he's fighting
in the UFC now,
one of the best Jujitsu guys in the UFC.
Really fantastic technique.
That's a,
that's a guy that you're connected to
forever now because of that,
I thank
him in my mind.
I think I'm a lot and I got promoted
like two weeks before the world
championships and my dad's always like,
life is about surprises in about
challenges and he's like,
you want this black belt?
And I was,
had submitted 55 straight and like,
yeah,
I want this challenge.
Let's see.
The little did I know it was going to
fucking shake my world and um,
but I,
I'm grateful for and it's great,
you know,
I have no,
no complaints in our and I wouldn't have
changed anything.
What is it like growing up being in
your,
you're going into this world of martial
arts with a guy like that as your
father.
Like what kind of advice did he
best advice?
I mean that's,
I think that's what made me who I am and
be able to really become my own man at
this age is the advice that my dad gave
me was such a,
you know,
it's easy in life to be drifted by
things and to be drifted by what people
say and what you personally think and
say and feel.
So,
you know,
always been able to have.
My Dad gave me a good advice and be able
to be my father and to teach me how to
be a man,
not just Jujitsu,
not just being good at technique,
but being able to be a good person,
being humble and being,
doing the best that you can.
Um,
I think that's what,
what allows me to become great at
Jujitsu and what allows me to become
great at whatever I do.
And you know,
for me,
I never really had that much training
sessions with my father.
People think he was there coaching me
everyday training on the sidelines with
water bottles and all this shit that
never existed in.
But one thing I do is I am very grateful
for is when I started to train really
hard at like 12 years old.
My Dad was in training at the academy
and my brother had passed and he was
just on his own search,
you know,
so he disappeared from the academy.
But every night I'd come home and he
would be there and he wouldn't ask me
how was school.
He would ask me how was training and I
would tell them,
oh man,
I got smashed or this happened,
or I got stuck in this position,
so at the dinner table or at the front
of the TV,
he would give me an answer to my problem
and he would give me advice,
you know,
whether it'd be about Jujitsu technique
or whether it be about what happened
here or how to,
how to react to what this person did.
And so my learning magic Jitsu really
growth happened over food,
over,
you know,
watching tv,
that's where I really learned what I
learned and then went back and trained
at the academy and practice what I was
taught.
So,
um,
most of my Jujitsu I learned through
verbal,
like just like conversations at the
dinner table and being able to,
do,
you know,
from that really
your dad had a,
that approach which was different than
voices approach and different than many
other people's approach.
This approach of mastering the physical
as well as mastering technique.
You know,
your dad is an accomplished Yogi,
is very physically strong.
That was one thing that really separated
him from a lot of the other people in
the Gracie family.
Yeah,
I definitely think so.
I think what separates my dad from not
only everybody in the family but from
most fighters is his,
not only his mental strength,
but his spiritual strength and he's a
very spiritual person.
And um,
I think that's huge,
you know,
especially now in my life,
realizing how important that is a part
of me,
I think being spiritually connected to
yourself and connected to whatever is
above us is,
is,
is something that really sometimes
things you can't explain happen when,
when you're that connected.
So my dad has always been a very
spiritual person.
You know,
he's,
he's doing all the things that he does
for his purpose,
you know,
if you talked to him for about money,
money is just secondary to,
to what his beliefs are.
And so as opposed to some people who
they will go against what they believe
in or they'll go against their
spirituality for a paycheck.
So my dad,
you know,
never,
never did that,
you know,
he never took,
sponsors for,
for beer or whatever,
you know,
because he doesn't believe that that's
necessarily the image that he wants to
go with.
And I think he's a very spiritual person
and he and I still,
even today I'm like surprised with how
much of a,
how much honor and,
and you know,
like,
you know,
it's just weird to describe how,
how,
how good he he's done for Jujitsu.
Really
the growing up in that atmosphere.
That's an incredible role model to have
that as your dad,
this guy that's got such a high moral
standard and he,
how did he get into yoga?
Because that's another thing that really
separated him from a lot of other
martial artists and really opened up a
lot of people's eyes to the beneficial
aspects of yoga.
So he got into yoga with this guy,
Orlando Kearney,
who is a Brazilian,
a yoga guy who basically his whole
theory was breathing with your movement.
So being able to.
Because Yoga is usually you breathe in,
you stop and you kind of breathe in.
You just do your movements and your kind
of just static,
but he kind of incorporated breathing
with movement and being able to like,
he would be like,
oh,
I'm gonna,
I'm an animal.
I'm a tiger.
So he would walk like a tiger and you
breathe and you look and he would
visualize himself like a tiger.
So he started to be able to to not only
do that as animal,
but he started to transfer it over to
Jujitsu and being able to.
Because this theory,
the guy's theory,
Orlando counties theory was animals are
perfect,
you know,
they move and they breathe and they
don't get tired and everything is in
sync.
So his whole theory was,
the better you can do that,
the more you can replicate that,
the more you're going to be able to be
efficient with your,
with whatever you do.
And the yoga for my data I guess was a
huge,
huge part.
And,
you know,
since a little kid he kind of always
told me about breathing and yoga and I
never cared and just kind of brushed it
off until when you get older and you
start really having difficulties when
you really start searching and really
start having problems,
then I started to start to breathe more
and now I think that the breathing is a
huge part of my,
my myself and it's a huge part of my
growth and it's a huge part of me being
able to be in,
be in tune with what I'm doing.
So I wouldn't take away that for
anything.
And I think that's probably one of the
biggest,
you know,
additions to my,
to myself that I could have added.
Yeah.
The Yoga breathing is a thing.
Pranayama,
is that what they call it?
I don't know.
Uh,
yeah.
Prada Yama is a,
is a huge part of,
uh,
what a lot of people are missing when it
comes to the idea of yoga.
They don't,
they don't understand that deep
breathing and breathing exercises are
there.
They're very difficult to do.
It's very difficult.
And it becomes like a factor of motivate
you can do this shit to write shitty dad
does with the abdomen.
Of course.
Yeah,
I do that.
Um,
what is that,
that,
that crazy video if folks who haven't
seen this is a documentary called choke.
It's an amazing documentary and it was
back when Hickson was competing in
Japan.
Valley Tudos was like 1995 or
[inaudible] 94 95.
And he,
there's a video that really like opened
up a lot of people's eyes of him doing
yoga and moving his stomach around with
these weird stomach exercises.
What,
what is that?
So your diaphragm.
Well,
I can kind of explained.
But basically your,
your,
your lungs are like,
oh,
like bottles,
they start screaming at the top and then
they,
they fill up to be big at the bottom.
So when you normally breathe you,
you're only filling up a small portion
of your lungs.
And when you get scared or when you have
anxiety,
everything is shortens your breath and
then screwed.
Yeah.
So that's what normally happens.
That's what's very normal for humans.
And being able to breathe through your
diaphragm is filling your lungs to the,
to the Max and,
and being able to control that is so
your diaphragm is a muscle and you need
to train it like a pushup or like
anything you do,
you need to train your muscles.
So the more you train your muscle,
the more control you have over it.
And that is just being able to have the
highest control of your diaphragm
muscle.
And when you have that kind of control,
you can filter your body out easier as
opposed to like right now,
if you don't train it,
you can't even like use your diaphragm.
So
sure
that just that simple movement is,
is it difficult,
uh,
is a difficult thing to do.
You have to train to do that.
And then being able to do that.
So what you're doing as you're breathing
in deep and then you're pulling your
diaphragm in
that actual exercise that you do is you
exhale,
you have no oxygen in your lungs,
and then you use your.
Then you just kind of massage your
diaphragm and you kind of just have that
kind of control so you're just
practicing like how to move it because
when you're training and you're tired
and if you have to think about to
breathe,
its already too much so you should just
have it.
It's like a one of those things that
start fire.
When you push out,
it's when you open it up,
it fills up naturally,
so if you learn how to breathe through
your diaphragm,
you naturally are going to filter way
more oxygen and you're going to have a.
everything's going to be better.
I like that's the reason why I can train
as long as I can train and why I can
stay clear.
And normally a lot of people they they
get cast out or they or they feel like
they're going to pass out or or they get
anxiety.
So being able to breathe correctly is a
huge part of my growth.
I think.
Learn that from your dad.
The diaphragm breathing.
What does he call it?
What it.
Is there a name for it?
No,
because we're not necessarily like yoga
crazy,
you know,
super into a specific type.
I think I just use yoga for my benefit
and I'm not like a ride or die of a
certain type of yoga.
I just kind of use yoga for my,
for,
for what I do for Jujitsu and how to
become a better person so I don't know
exactly what the name is or anything.
It's just being able to breathe and
being able to use my diaphragm and being
able to stay calm and learn how to
manage my energy.
So that has helped me not only with
Jujitsu but anything new I do or if I'm
going to come here on an interview,
if I start to get nervous,
you know,
I breathe in,
it goes away.
So the breathing has helped me become,
is given me an opportunity to do
everything that I can do.
Yeah.
I do a lot of deep breathing exercises,
um,
in a sensory deprivation tank.
And one of the things that I do is a
long breathing.
Like I'll,
I'll have an inhale that lasts a minute
and then the exhale last a minute and is
a,
it's a discipline,
like you have to force yourself to
maintain that pace because you get to a
panic.
He just want to fuck this,
but you can stay alive and keep doing
it.
You can do it and you can still stay
alive and keep doing it,
but it's,
it becomes this weird thing where your
body starts freaking out.
It's like breathe,
motherfucker,
stop breathing out,
breathe,
breathe in,
breathe out for a minute and then
breathe in for a minute.
Breathe out for a minute
there.
Yeah,
there is different types of exercises.
I know,
like sometimes if I'm,
if I'm trying to stay calm,
I'm going to breathe slower.
If I'm trying to get energy,
I'm going to breathe faster.
If I'm trying to maintain a high pace,
I'm going to,
you know,
it's like a car when you drive a car,
if you're driving slow,
uh,
but if you drive fast cars,
so you need like when I train,
if I'm in a very intense,
I'll breathe loud.
Like so to make sure I'm getting enough
oxygen to,
to keep up with what I'm doing
physically.
So I definitely am very grateful for
being able to have that a part of my
life.
And it's cool,
man.
It's really good.
I only experienced that breathing for
the first time in Jujitsu after a
lifelong martial arts.
I'd never heard anybody breathe like
that until I started training and uh,
at John jocks academy and hearing
people,
you know,
hearing like black belts roll here guys,
really what the fuck are they doing it?
But yeah,
it was a white belt.
I was walking around with everybody
doing it was,
it was such a strange thing.
And John Jack explained to me that,
you know,
when,
when you breathe out you will definitely
breathe in,
force yourself to breathe out and then
get rid of all the car.
Yeah.
The bad air in your body and breathe in
fresh oxygen.
And that the forcing it out is something
that people don't concentrate enough on.
Yeah.
When you normally want to breathe,
you breathe in and then that only fills
up that top part,
you know.
So if you,
I mean is there a lot about it,
but I think it's definitely a huge part
of my success today and it's also a huge
part of my dad's.
Yeah.
I would recommend to anybody who is
interested in this to go and just look
up various yoga,
breathing videos on youtube and just
follow along with them and you'd get a
great benefit from that and it's
something that people don't really think
too much about,
about concentrating and controlling your
breathing.
And there's also a great meditative
quality to that too.
I'm one of the first breathing exercises
I ever did when I was really young.
So many told me that you can meditate by
just concentrating only on your breath,
just not,
not even a breathing exercise,
but just breathe in good and out bad and
think of nothing but those things.
I think as you're breathing in,
you're taking in oxygen and as you're
breathing out,
you're just pumping out in with the good
out the bad.
I just think of those things and think
only of your breath and by forcing
yourself to concentrate on that,
it sort of filters out everything in
your life and it all becomes like
background.
Everything else sort of calms down and
you get this feeling after you're done
doing that.
If you do that for an hour,
everything else sort of like the.
The importance of things that you
thought was so big and so crazy in your
life and all this is fucked up,
but what am I going to do about that?
It seems less important after that.
Yeah.
I think the breathing keeps me in touch
with my spirituality and being able to
breathe.
Like I've gotten into some,
some super gnarly trances where I'm,
you know,
really connected to whatever is above us
and that's through the breathing so that
like being able to breathe and like
after your training or during your
training or however you like to do.
It has given me like a huge,
huge benefits and I,
I connect myself too when I'm training,
like being able to breathe puts me in a,
in a very animal like state where it's
like me against you.
It's not,
I'm not thinking about what you're
doing.
I'm not thinking about,
oh,
I am thinking about what you're doing,
but I'm not thinking about things.
It's more of like a feeling and that
feeling.
The closer you are to that feeling,
it gives you almost above your mind
above you can actually think it's more
like a of a,
of a animal instinct and that like since
I started to really incorporate the
breathing and the connecting it to my
Jujitsu,
it's given me way more.
Well,
there's a,
a whole group of people that use
breathing.
It's called holotropic breathing and
they use it to achieve psychedelic
states.
They have achieved psychedelic states
for sure.
Like what's the most intense state
you've ever achieved while breathing?
Oh,
I mean I think a couple of times after
training when I'm really exhausted,
like I'm very,
very,
very exhausted to a point where you want
me to stop training like 30,
40 minutes before and then after I'll do
a breathing,
breathing in and out and I'll just keep
going into the breathing and as I,
as I start to breathe and start to get
more in tune,
there's nothing exists and it's just me
and I can almost see the particles in
the air and I can.
It's just like a sensation that,
you know,
I've only felt a couple of times but I
definitely have gotten in touch with
like,
it's very,
it's very intense to like to get to that
point where you just feel.
It's almost like you can see the air.
It's almost like you can see and like
all these little things and it's pretty
intense.
So I've gotten to that point a couple of
times or three or four points were where
I feel like,
wow,
I can actually feel the energy.
And it was a great thing,
man.
I'm like,
after if you feel high and you smile and
you're like,
man,
this is crazy and crazy that you can,
how much we're capable of as humans and
how much will do is so big and you know,
you think about the actual world and how
the actual world is,
is like this planet.
We should be in touch with something
above,
you know,
we should be able to in touch with how
this got to this or how there's
Waterhouse Salami.
All these things that we today are like,
oh no,
that's this,
that's this or this is that.
It's so much more.
You can explain shit,
you know.
So it's like really?
I go a lot more about my feelings these
days than anything else.
You know,
over my rational decision.
I kind of try to feel how things are.
I feel how people are feel,
how I feel,
how I,
how I feel about this training session
or whatever it is.
I kind of try to go more about feeling
because that's never failed me before.
So this,
these breathing techniques and he states
that you achieve the,
they give you a sort of a fresh
perspective.
They give you a perspective of
recognizing the greatness and the beauty
and the magnitude of life that sometimes
escapes us and our normal everyday path
where you just sort of take for granted
that that's a door.
This is the house go outside,
that's the sky.
It becomes normal,
but these breathing techniques and the
just the psychedelic states that you
achieve from them allow you to almost
like a reset button.
Yeah,
it's pretty cool,
man.
I really recommend breathing in for
anybody who is doing anything in their
life,
whether it'd be something you know,
whether you're trying to get through a
tough situation,
whether you're arguing with your
girlfriend or whether you're stuck in
traffic or whether you're trying to stay
calm while somebody was trying to choke
you.
The breathing has given me and it took a
long time.
It's not like,
oh boom.
I started breathing.
I got it.
It's actually took a long time before
you really value it because when my dad
started telling me this,
I kind of didn't care and I was just
like,
whatever,
whatever.
He's got all kinds of.
She's always telling me Shit.
So,
but after,
you know,
the older I got,
the more I kind of started to have
stress and have to deal with this
pressure and then I kind of started to
do it every once in a while and then now
it's at a point where the past few years
I've really stepped it up a lot and it's
really a big part of my,
my,
my training and my and everything.
I do.
So even when I skateboard now,
I'm like trying to breathe and I'm
trying to like,
keep,
keep everything in tune so I can do the
best I can do
the last time.
Um,
when,
when we had a dinner together,
your dad was still talking about
competing.
He had,
he had stopped,
but he was still thinking about
fighting.
He was still,
there was people,
you know,
there's always a threat on the
underground is one of the big themes in
the underground is Hixon by Armbar.
They would,
they would joke around about anything,
you know,
who'd win Godzilla versus King Kong
kicks in by arm bar was,
it is,
it was just an inside joke when someone,
something could be answered.
Someone just right Hixon via arm bar.
Um,
did,
did he have any regrets that he didn't
fight any of the big name guys that he
didn't continue?
We were talking about him fighting
fader.
He,
you know,
he was,
uh,
he was saying that if he did fight
someone who would want to fight fate or
who is the champion of pride at the
time.
Yeah,
I think that,
I don't know if there's any regrets or
anything.
I think it was just a time in my dad's
life where,
well,
right after my brother passed,
you know,
he,
he got offered to fight Sakharova and it
was a big,
big payday and it was a big,
big fight.
And of course my dad being the man he
is,
he wasn't going to just leave the family
to go train for a fight and take his
selfish needs into consideration.
So he kind of just took her,
which turned away the fight and kind of
gave his energy to the family and try to
do what he could to help everybody.
And after that time passes,
there's still like some,
some people wanting to have them fired
and he was maybe five Fado and maybe
with this.
But I think after that moment he kind of
just,
the time passed,
you know,
his fighting that time had passed for
his,
even though he was still possibility for
him to fight,
I think that he necessarily.
He was ready to fight and as a man he
was ready to die.
But I don't think that necessarily it
was.
I'm glad that he didn't fight after
that.
I'm glad that he,
you know,
it happened the way it did and he
retired the way he did and he still has
the greatest image.
So I think that it's,
I think it's a great thing that it went
away.
Did you know,
like,
my dad is a great fighter and he's great
mind and that separates him from
everybody else,
but I think that everything went fine
even though whatever happened,
I think that he didn't need to fight.
He didn't need to prove anything to
anybody else.
And even if he did fight,
win or lose,
that would have been his hammer his
best,
you know?
So,
um,
I think my dad did enough from when he
was 15,
when he was 40.
He proved enough people wrong.
He did what he had to do.
He was ready,
you know,
you don't know where.
It's like nobody knows what it's like to
be having to be ready to fight,
to die at any moment.
Motherfuckers come in your academy and
they challenge you.
You got this guy telling him that he
doesn't believe in Jujitsu.
So nobody knows what that feels like to
have to be ready.
Everybody now,
Oh,
you want a fight?
Okay,
give me three months or six months.
I'm going to train for my fighter,
but to be,
have to be ready at any time,
any moment,
no matter what.
You know,
that's where my dad lives,
like from 15 years old to 40 years old.
So he needed to retire,
he needed to be able to not be ready.
He needed to be able to release and I
think that was the best thing for him
and it was the best thing for his life.
And now I think it's all good and it's
just a very tough situation,
man.
I lot of people don't know how serious
my dad took.
Of course people know how serious but
you only see the glory,
you know,
you don't see how he really is as a man
and how,
how you,
you really make it your life,
you know,
and fighting is a big thing is probably
the hardest thing to do.
And you know,
that guy was ready anytime,
anywhere where approved,
very approved.
The family was,
was better ready to prove that he was
better and you know,
that's what gives me inspiration to,
to wake up in the mornings and do what I
do.
And I only really do it because of him
and my brother.
I only really compete because of him and
my brother.
I only,
the more my motivation is to keep,
keep him happy and to keep this family
remember instead of just,
Oh,
the gracies work good when nobody knew
Jujitsu,
but now everybody doesn't.
They're not the nowhere.
So I,
I think it's important for my life.
I've already kind of am willing to
sacrifice my life and willing to
sacrifice whatever I feel and how I like
things to be for the bigger objective,
which is to keep my father and my
grandfather,
you know,
alive and well in their legacy.
Will you there for any of those
challenge matches?
When Anjo came to the,
uh,
I was.
So Joe,
I was a little kid at that time.
I was like maybe four or five years old
and um,
I remember the days happening and it's
happening.
I wasn't there at the specific advice
because not even my dad was at the time
and my dad was at home in breakfast and
the guys came and called them.
I was like,
dude,
because in Japan were invading the
academy.
So my dad got up and like got ready to
go to the academy and that was like
another thing like you just waked up
that I was going to be another day for
him to go on a bike ride and then
motherfuckers outside the academy ready
to challenge you with all this press and
you know,
if you lose,
it's just as like a real fight,
you know,
for folks don't know.
That's
one historical match that apparently a
gordon has just said he seen is a Yogi
and Joe who is a pro wrestler and MMA
fighter in Japan just showed up at the
academy and Hixon took him into a back
room and beat the fucking shit out of
him.
And Your Dad,
you know,
he,
he came out and Yohji Andrew's face
faces,
photos of his face online.
We can see what your dad did to him.
But I've heard all sorts of stories
about the way he choked him and all
sorts of,
you know,
I don't know.
True story,
true story.
I seen the video many times and I used
to bring my friends over when I was a
kid and show them the fights and
everything is in Joe's face up on that
screen.
So the story behind that as he came into
the academy and,
and it's a long story,
but I'll kind of sum it up,
but basically came in to challenge my
dad and my dad was like,
okay,
fine.
So he shows up at the academy and they
kicked all the press out because he
didn't want them to film in case
whatever happened.
So he kicked all the press out and then
just the guy on Joe and his manager were
in the,
in the academy.
My Dad was having a car or my dad's
black belt was having a class where
there was a bunch of students there and
yeah man,
just like everybody says,
my dad beat the shit out of this guy.
Like this guy came in and my dad
instantly took them down,
mounted him up.
And in the beginning of the fight,
the guy turned his back to try to get
put to sleep because he realized he was
going to lose,
so he gave him his back to get to sleep
in.
My Dad was like,
no,
you're going to take more punishment,
you're not going to get put to sleep so
easily,
you know,
so he kept beating them bad and it was
like,
it was hard to see,
you know,
as even as a kid and he broke his nose,
you can hear his nose break and it's a
pretty big beating.
And then after he fought,
put them to sleep,
he called the press and the press came
in and took pictures and everything.
Andrea went back to Japan saying that he
got jumped by the academy,
that we all jumped him.
And then my dad had filmed it,
brought,
brought the video to Japan,
was like,
look,
this is the fight.
Showed all the press.
And they were like,
oh yeah,
they all like,
you know,
thought it was very bad that he had lied
and said that he got jumped in front of
TV.
So anyways,
yeah.
That fight is true and what isn't it put
that online?
I don't know.
That's a good question,
but I think he just because it's martial
arts history.
Yeah,
I'll,
I'll talk to them.
Itunes.
You probably make 100 grand,
you know,
sell that thing on itunes for a buck and
you probably make $100,000
easy.
Easy.
I think so.
I mean maybe I'll promote it,
let me know man,
let me know when it's up.
I'll put it on twitter.
I'll put it on the podcast.
I'll let people know I pay a buck to
watch that.
Right.
I'll pick 20 bucks to watch that Shit.
That to me,
that's one of the great challenge
matches in martial arts history.
I mean there's your dad versus a Hugo
Duarte on the beach in Rio.
There's like a few of those that you can
see.
You know there's a few of those which is
fucking crazy.
I mean they were duking it out on the
beach in sand know pretty,
pretty,
pretty wild.
You could see that,
but that wasn't the prolonged beating.
You know,
he let him up after he kicked his ass.
I think my dad,
because there were so many videos of
everybody fighting the gracie in action
videos had came out,
all these videos were out.
I think my dad just wanted to keep
something for himself and wanting to
have some kind of power because
everybody had taken all the footage and
everything was used in whichever way,
you know,
my dad probably never got paid a cent
for the gracie in action videos are or
anything.
So I think he was just wanting to keep
something that he had power and,
and,
and it was good,
you know,
at this moment he has no value to that.
Yeah.
A dollar 99,
50 bucks.
There was also from the outside,
there was always the um,
the talk was always,
especially because uh,
you know,
I've been working for the UFC since 97,
so the people that I was working with
like Campbell Mclaren and all those
guys,
they had been there from ufc one and
they were,
you know,
they'd said that the reason why I'm your
uncle didn't put your brother in our,
didn't put your father and instead put
hoists in that.
The reason why he did that was because
he couldn't control Hickson.
Hickson was just,
you know,
he was the best of the family.
Everybody knew he was the best of
family,
but that Horian knew that if he put
Hixson Hixson wasn't gonna,
you know,
Hickson was going to do whatever you
want it to.
He was,
he wasn't going to listen to him and he
wouldn't be able to control him the way
he possibly controlled everybody else.
Is there any truth to that or what is
it?
So there's a lot of different things
that happened in that kind of time and
Arrow,
you know,
one reason why he's fought in the UFC
and I,
my dad,
because my dad was the best,
you know,
my dad would tap out hoists with one
hand and in his belt before his fight.
So there was no doubt of that.
One excuse I think was that Horian
looked or hoist look more frail.
He looked like a more of a normal guy.
So they wanted to make him.
They wanted that to be able to prove
that you do to is better.
But ultimately,
I don't know if that's true or not and I
don't know the exact reason,
but basically before that situation,
a Horian and my dad had a,
had a,
uh,
they kind of started to separate.
They kind of started,
you know,
to go their own ways.
And I think in that situation,
again,
I don't know,
100 percent,
but that's what I kind of thing happened
and I'm sure horry and felt more control
over,
over hoist.
Then he did it with my father.
My Dad was kind of already starting to
find his own way and do his own thing.
And um,
yeah,
I dunno,
I don't know too much about it because
we never really talked about that far
back.
But even I think I have talked to my dad
about it,
but I forget because that's not really
that important these days for me.
Well,
you know,
Horian gets a lot of.
Whoops.
Whoring gets a lot of grief.
But I mean he was such a great promoter
of Jujitsu and if it wasn't for him
doing that,
it wasn't for him putting on those
gracie in videos and promoting them.
And promoting Jujitsu and promoting
Gracie Jujitsu.
It,
yeah,
probably has a huge part of what Jujitsu
and MMA is today that um,
he definitely made his value huge
because not only did he create the UFC
but he,
you know,
came to America,
he spread it,
he,
he was the one challenge doing all the
challenges in doing everything.
So he was the reason really.
And my dad was just a soldier,
was the guy that one representing and
ready to do what he had to do and you
know,
it's like Carlos and Leo.
Leo was the representative and Carlos
was the guy who kind of took care of the
academy and it was the theory behind the
diets and the theory behind the names
and stuff.
So I think neither one of them,
I think they're both responsible for,
for the movement.
And yeah,
I think it was a great thing.
Horian,
they,
he did like even as academy,
look at his academy day,
it's like a museum,
you know,
he has,
it's like a five star hotel with shower
head look at my academy and it's nothing
like that,
you know,
my academy is,
it has some pictures and stuff,
but it's not focused on that.
My focusing is on the match,
will retrain what I teach.
I'm not focused on promoting and being
able to sell Jujitsu and being able to
expand.
Why the gracies you know,
like for me,
you come in,
you're gonna be,
you're gonna come to me and telling me
if you know and you want to.
And horian was,
he did a great job in expanding and
showing the world in your face.
Like,
here,
look,
this is what happens when this happens
and this.
So he was a great tool for the family
and a great,
you know,
he,
he made it happen.
You know,
he,
he created a lot.
Yeah,
all of us fans of Jujitsu or Horian
Gracie,
a huge debt of gratitude without a
doubt.
And also because he produced his sons
that are also great promoters of Jujitsu
and the great the Gracie breakdowns I
one of my favorite things about after
submissions after this,
a submission in the UFC,
a Henna here on will get together and
discuss with,
with great technical explanation all the
various aspects of where someone went
wrong,
where things went right,
what was the proper adjustment,
what they did to get out of a bad
situation.
Really very,
very educational.
And if you watch that show a UFC
ultimate insider,
it's on UFC ultimate insider.
It's so great because first of all,
henry is so good at explaining these
things.
He's so articulate and so charismatic
when it comes to these breakdowns of
positions is so much enthusiasm.
You know,
you watch these guys talk about these
things and it makes you want to train.
I mean,
it really does.
It's a,
it's really good stuff and it just shows
how much is going on with Jujitsu.
For folks who don't know,
there's so much going on,
you know,
for people don't know they're looking
at.
They think,
oh,
this guy's trying to choke that guy.
And he's trying to stop it,
but it's all about the and the intricate
details of leverage and movement.
And these guys do a real good job
breaking that down.
Yeah,
they do do a great job breaking it down.
And personally for me,
I've never been one to teach online or
through magazines or through stuff.
I think I believe the Jujitsu is a lot
more about feel and I don't,
I,
I kind of don't do that.
I kind of disagree with myself teaching
online or through videos and all that
stuff.
I kind of,
I want to be able to feel and look
somebody in the eyes if I'm going to
teach them Jujitsu.
And so yeah,
that's my philosophy behind that,
but you know,
they're doing a great job of spreading
it to all those people who can't get to
them and they do what they do.
I'm not really a to in control of what
they do or how they do it.
But I know for myself,
I,
I kind of don't do that and I kind of
stick to my academy and where I teach
and I focused on that kind of stuff.
Right.
But what I'm talking about is their
explanations of those guys are in mma,
who rate
for the native,
you know,
those guys,
they,
they explained to the T.
it's one of the more difficult aspects
of doing commentary is explaining not
just recognizing positions and what's
going to happen,
but explaining to people positions and
explaining what were the defenses were
the offenders and doing it all in real
time while the mat scrambles are going
on and trying to like,
you know,
what arms and Japanese at the left arm
with his left arm and you know,
you got to process all this stuff and
you had,
does he have his hand,
his hands locked.
I can't see.
And try to put it all into together and
then explain it to the layman to explain
to the person who doesn't train at home
where it's just a massive bodies.
You know?
That's why I just focused on competing
and training better for me.
Competing training and teaching.
Yeah,
well I like that philosophy of looking
someone in the eye and,
and training because there is that
aspect of if you put a video out there
you don't know who's learning your shit,
you know?
Yeah,
of course.
Very personal,
right?
Jujitsu and it's very personal.
I think so too.
You know,
and while I'm still competing,
last thing I want is my enemies to be
able to see what I do and see how I do
things.
So yeah,
there's no way I would do that.
One of the interesting aspects about you
and your Jujitsu career too,
is that there's a lot of variation in
Jujitsu and Jujitsu styles.
There's a lot of new stuff that's come
along,
a lot of new techniques,
a lot of new strategies,
but your,
your attacks and your Jujitsu,
very much like your father's.
It's very much traditional Jujitsu,
you know,
and there was a,
there was a time when Vinny Magalhaes
was on the ultimate fighter with a
Minotauro Nogueira and he was talking
about minotauro.
Nogueira is Jujitsu and he said it's
very basic,
very basic features are.
I mean it's all got really mad at him,
but he,
he said he didn't mean it in a bad way.
What he meant by.
It's the basics but honed to a laser
sharp edge.
Like there's nothing wrong with the,
they're the foundation of Jujitsu and
when I watch you compete,
you're using the real traditional
techniques of Jujitsu.
You're not.
There's nothing like a tricky that
people haven't seen before.
It's just Jujitsu that's done to
perfection.
Yeah.
I think that the tricks they work
sometimes and they work if it's some
good moment,
you know,
like these,
these new things that happen in these
new ways to defeat your opponent.
So I'm always looking for a situation
that's going to work all the time,
you know,
so these tricks,
the good positions or stuff,
they demand a lot out of you and they
only work if that situation happens.
So I'm not concerned with trapping
myself into a position that's good for
me because I count on not being in good
positions.
I count on being in a bad position.
I count on being in another position,
so for me I'm,
I'm,
I'm leaving my training sessions open
to,
to what may happen and I don't like try
to get to a certain position and then
began my training.
That's what I feel like happens most of
the time.
It's due to these days as you want to
get to this grip,
this grip and then from here you're
going to start training.
So to get to that position where you
have your special grips and everything,
it takes a lot of energy and it takes a
lot of strength and I kind of based my
attitude so on leverage and techniques
so that it'll work when I'm fresh,
when I'm tired,
if I'm fighting a guy who's bigger than
me,
it doesn't depend on physical strength.
So that's where kind of my dad kind of
forced me because I didn't always think
like this and you kind of given me the,
not only the,
the technique and the leverage,
but showing me that it's possible
proving to me firsthand that it's
possible for you to beat your opponents
with leverage.
To not use dream to say,
so my like,
you know,
been been promoting this like little
mini warrior in my mind for a long time
of how to be not only mentally but
physically in training wise and
spiritually and it's been,
it's all helped me in and he's a great,
huge part of,
of,
of my success.
One of the things I took from the
conversation with your dad,
we was talking about the various aspects
did you did too,
but he was saying that first and
foremost,
one of the most important weapons that
he has is his defense.
That is always safe.
He said,
at any position,
I'm always safe.
He doesn't that.
He concentrates on that.
And then the other thing was that when
he moved from one position,
I never forget this conversation.
He goes,
we all started point zero from zero in
the neutral point I moved to one and
when I get to one,
I'm not going back to zero.
It sounds like he said he's a very
interesting person,
you know,
but it's true.
If you watch his fights,
he rarely loses positions.
There's no sloppy scrambles know.
It's one of the things that I criticize
people sometimes about an MMA,
like guys leave too much space.
They go for things in a way they're not
in control of the position and he never
did that when when he would mount a god,
that motherfucker would stay mounted
when he mounted the guy was just a
matter of time before we got an arm bar
or whatever he got for you.
Yeah.
It's pretty cool to see that the,
I guess like everything in life,
everything goes back to the basics and I
didn't like plan to have a certain type
of style.
I didn't like,
Oh,
I'm gonna.
Just try to train this style.
Just submissions only.
No,
I didn't plan that.
I'm planning and it's not like I'm going
to start a fight and I'm just going to
go for an arm rocker.
I'm going to go for a crazy submission
from nowhere.
It's not like that either.
You're not gonna get that,
but my training sessions are to like
you're.
My Dad says to get to the next better
position to get to the next better
position to get to the submission.
So I'm never stopping my mind,
I've never stopped in my training,
I don't stop in a place and be like,
okay,
I'm going to breathe here for a second
or I don't do that.
I kind of always am looking for the next
place to get to the finish line and
that's created a very aggressive style
because I'm always looking for the next
place to be and it's not necessarily
like,
oh,
I just go for submissions from anywhere.
No,
I'm going for.
Sometimes it may be to pass the guard or
maybe to do to get his leg off my hip or
whatever it is that may happen.
So it's not like I'm just thinking about
submissions or I'm not thinking about
doing crazy.
The tricky stuff,
it's just that those stuff may not fall
into what I'm mentally trying to do.
Your objective,
my objective,
and I think that's the biggest thing.
I don't think too much about it.
I just think about how am I going to get
to a next better place?
How am I going to put him here?
So it just comes kind of naturally at
this point.
I can't even.
Not trained that way if I try to train
any different way,
my Jujitsu sucks so it's become A.
I'm glad.
I'm very grateful that it's become like
this and I have this type of style and I
had gotten as good as I got with the
basics and with what I with the tools
that I had.
So I'm,
I'm super stoked.
That became an issue in Abu Dhabi with a
lot of wrestlers that wrestlers would
take guys down and just hold them in
positions and not go for submissions.
Just try to go for points and you know,
and people would get furious.
It'd be like,
well this isn't Jujitsu,
but some people felt like the only way
to compete with these guys is to do what
they're doing is to fight smart.
The only way you can win is to,
to,
to fight on points.
Would you rather lose on points then
when?
By holding a guy down?
Yeah.
I have lost like,
that doesn't bother you.
It does.
I mean you don't.
You show me a good loser.
I'll show you a loser,
but you know.
Yeah.
I rather lose on points with keeping my
mentality always with the objective to
get into a better place then to stop my
game and to find out how I'm going to
win this match while using the time on
my side.
So I have fought matches where I lost
when I could won,
I was winning on points and then I went
for something or I try to advance the
position,
then I lost it and then doing and then
whatever.
The guy swept me and then I lost because
of the time right now.
So I have lost matches like that and it
served as a good learning experience and
everything and you know,
yeah,
I'd rather lose on points then to sit
there and stop the game and wait for the
time to,
to,
to run out because I will.
I don't know if I would feel like shit,
you know,
I feel like deep inside me I have a
thing that I feel like really bad if I
don't try to go for the next position.
I feel guilty almost.
So like my grandfather's.
So you were your Jujitsu and your,
um,
your,
your path is clearly a work in progress
and even though you've achieved the
great heights of being an Abu Dhabi
world champion,
while you're training and fighting,
you're always competing with that very
specific mindset.
So any setbacks are just going to be
educational experiences.
You learn from those setbacks and then
next time you even greater,
which is why when you came in,
was it second place in 2011?
A third,
third place,
2011.
They came back and fucking dominated in
2013.
That was a big leap man.
Yeah,
that was good one.
It was a good.
I think honestly,
I think I was ready for it and maybe if
I would've won in 2011,
it wouldn't have been the same.
Or if I went in 2009,
who knows what would happen.
But you know,
I feel like now I'm ready.
I don't make more excuses about anything
and if I don't win,
it's my fault.
If I,
if the guy was good enough to stall me
out,
he was good enough to start me out.
So I have to come up with some thing to
be able to be better than he is,
so I don't really take it in,
criticize them anymore.
If the guy just stalls on me,
I expect that the guys are not going to
want to fight me into.
They're going to want to start and get
some points in,
feel good.
I expect that and I trained that
situation and I'm ready for that.
And so far so good.
You know,
I've been on a,
on a good,
good run lately.
Have you ever seen the video where Eddie
Bravo and I were talking about your
magic?
Dad was great for folks who don't know
in the finals that dude was trying to
stall crawling out and starts making
chicken noises.
He's gone.
And for a Jujitsu Guy,
I mean,
do you want to talk about the ultimate
mind?
Fuck,
you're not just fighting against the son
of the greatest ever,
but the greatest ever is making chicken
noises that you.
Yeah,
that was fucked up
because.
Because it started.
When he did that,
I was like,
man,
now I can't let this get to me too.
You know,
because my dad is over here,
like of course I have to kind of try to
keep in the final match.
I fought a guy who I had beaten many
times before,
so,
um,
I knew that I could win,
but if I were to start letting myself
believe that I was gonna win,
Oh,
I'm going to win because I had already
won.
It was going to completely mess up my
mind.
So I went into the fight like he was the
most difficult fight of my life.
And when my dad started to get Fred,
I knew he was going to back away.
I knew he was gonna start me out and it
was not getting to me.
I was just like trying to do what I
could do.
I'm not going to go crazy because he's
not wanting to fight me.
I was expecting that the reps were gonna
warn him and take away points and I was
going to let that happen.
And Yeah,
when my dad was like,
when you did that,
I was like,
man,
I kicked chrome.
Don't let it get it to you.
Don't let that shit get to you,
man.
Don't think,
don't let him.
You have to make it so that me.
So you and your dad are fighting
together.
Not against each other.
I didn't want to let him where he said
like affect my train of thought,
put more pressure on me to have to do
something.
So I kinda kept my cool and thank God
like shortly after that he,
he got a point taken away for crystal
clean and then he went for the take down
and I got him in a good guillotine.
So it all worked out as well.
And that victory right there,
right there is like the happiest moment
of my life.
That's the greatest feeling ever.
And I think my dad still still so happy.
I mean I haven't seen my dad that
everybody that comes up and talks to me,
he's like,
you're dad hasn't been this happy in so
long and to see him so proud and so,
so stoked to finally achieve that number
one place is a,
is a good thing.
It was such a beautiful poetic moment
too.
When the guy shoots for the take down,
you immediately lock it up like this is
why this guy was
stolen
right into the jaws of death.
You lock that thing on.
Perfect too.
That was beautiful.
I mean he tapped out within like a
couple of seconds.
It was over.
Yeah.
When he went for like.
I mean I,
I have,
I'm dangerous from a lot of different
places,
you know,
but when he went from my leg I was like,
thanks buddy.
I was like this great Christmas present
and like boom,
everything fits so good.
And,
and uh,
it was,
it was a good good.
I mean it was a great show in,
in,
in that success of that competition kind
of just came from a lot of I trained my
ass off,
like sacrifice everything.
And you know,
in life that's what you gotta do when
you want something,
you know,
whether whatever field it is you have to
kind of really see what you wanted.
And I saw my potential and I used it and
I kind of,
you know,
anybody who saw me trained so hard.
I trained for that fight.
I was ready to win.
Yeah.
You want to see something crazy.
Pull up a kron gracie Ninja training.
It's some bars in Santa Monica that's.
I saw this the other day.
Somebody put it on my message board.
On the thread of this particular
podcast.
When the podcast was announced you,
do you do this often?
Is this wild video of you climbing up on
these bars in Santa Monica?
You climb to the top and then you.
You're swinging like here's the video he
climbed.
How often do you do this?
I mean,
I live in Santa Monica,
so I go there all the time and I kind of
always do just like some workouts and I
like to be at the beach and in the
ocean,
but this is just like a joke,
you know,
like it just kind of a little trick,
you know?
Yeah.
Well this little trick,
he's jumping nine feet from one bar to
the next swinging and then catching with
his arms like a monkey.
I mean this is some wild shit.
Dude.
This is on the chimpanzee shit
that day.
Nate was the one filming that and he was
super stoked on it.
And how often do you do that?
I go down to the bars or at least like
once or twice a week just to kind of,
you know,
I do the ropes or climb the ropes for my
forearms and I do some of his stuff,
but you know,
that's never like the biggest part of my
training or it's never the most
important thing.
It's always come secondary to training,
Jujitsu and my specific stuff I got
going on.
But when you train all day,
everyday you got to find ways to keep
yourself entertained and keep yourself
enjoying what you're doing.
And I hate being in a Jew.
I had been in a gym.
Weightlifting,
gym.
Human.
Yeah,
weightlifting gym and I hate being in
there like working out and so if I'm
going to go on a bike ride,
I'll go outside.
If I'm going to run out,
go outside,
I like to feel the fresh air and kind of
enjoy myself while I'm in this kind of
hill that I live in.
It's kind of held perpetual training,
you mean?
Yeah.
How much physical training do you do
besides the Jujitsu?
I do a lot of energy too.
I do a lot of everything I run,
I bike,
I swim,
I do.
And when you do it,
like what are the objectives?
Like when you,
when you do you're running,
are you monitoring your heart rate?
He doing sprints,
eat tabata intervals.
Like what do you,
how do you ever.
I do all the different types,
you know,
sometimes I do just a long distance run
while run an hour and 10 or 20 minutes
straight and then the goal would be for
that would be endurance and then I'll do
some days where I'll just do sprints
upstairs or some days I'll just do a
bike long bike rides or you know,
all those things.
I kind of just,
some days it's more explosive and some
days it's more long distance and I just
use it as a tool,
as an addition to two other things I do
and I felt like since I really started
to put my energy into other things,
it's made my Jujitsu better because the
more in life when you sacrifice in one
direction,
no matter what it is,
it gives.
It makes you better.
I don't know how,
I don't know what it's like something
with the universe where no,
even if you say,
oh,
I'm going to wake up at six in the
morning to go do 20 pushups and then go
back to sleep.
That is gonna make you better at what
you do because you are going to start to
create this energy to,
to achieve your goals.
So once I started to really dedicate
myself,
not only with Jujitsu but with breathing
and,
and physical strength and,
and technical strength and mental
strength and all these different ways
that I can build myself as a,
as the best I can be,
it really went to show,
you know,
it really made a big improvement.
Since that moment.
Do you find that the physical training
helps prevent injuries?
Do you find?
I do.
I think it's important.
I think physical is training should be
done at a right time because if you get
a white belt and you start telling them
all right,
you got to be physically strong and you
tell them to start working out and
running and then he's going to create.
His training is going to be based on his
physical strength.
So my advice is the physical strength is
to,
uh,
to add to your technical ability.
It's not to take away from your
technical ability and make you rely on
your strength and really make you rely
on your physical attributes.
So I always kind of don't push for,
for guys in my academy to work out until
they reach a brown or black belt level,
then there they can,
they can start adding to their technique
because if you get too strong,
I've seen happen many times where guys
will take steroids and then they'll get
so strong and they'll lose their
technique.
So I never wanted that to happen to me.
I knew that the strength was always
gonna be there if I,
if I worked on it.
So I think it's important for you to
build your technique and then secondary,
you know,
your strength can keep,
keep your technique going because of
course if you don't have any physical
strain,
your technique will,
will,
will fade,
you know,
so you gotta have enough strength to
keep it,
to keep it going.
Do you have a trainer that helps you
with your physical strength workouts or
do you just know?
I got myself,
that's,
that's how I count on all that you've
learned over all the years of martial
arts.
Yeah.
And like I said,
you know,
like it,
it took,
um,
you know,
when you're,
when you're training for fights and when
you're,
when you're getting ready.
My Dad left to Brazil when like,
oh,
when I was 18,
so I didn't have a coach,
I didn't have nobody.
My Dad was in another country,
I didn't have a coach,
I didn't have a strength trainer,
I didn't have nobody to give me any kind
of advice.
So for a long time I was kind of like,
oh man,
this sucks.
Like fuck,
everybody should be helping me.
My Dad should be helping me.
I should have a trainer,
I should have fucking somebody,
you know,
write my stuff down and I should have
all this stuff and you know,
I should be sponsored by Nike and I
should have,
you know,
like all these things that like,
I compared myself to Colby Ryan.
But um,
as you get better,
you realize that stuff's not going to
happen.
And,
and I kind of got to a point where I
kind of stopped making excuses and I
kind of started to blame myself for,
for,
for my own success.
Not blaming other reasons,
not blaming because I didn't have this
or because I didn't have this or because
my dad wasn't here,
so I'm grateful for my dad taught me as
much as you can for as much as he did
and got to a certain point where I
stopped blaming.
I stopped blaming anybody for anything
and I kind of just put all everything
into my hands.
So that was my,
what I do now and how my schedule is now
as a result of a lot of years of being
on my own and being.
Of course I've had help here and there,
but nobody fully embraced being my help.
So of course I picked.
I picked from the help from I can get
from wherever I can get all this guy
taught me this one thing,
I'll do it.
So I kind of go around and using my
experience to make the best training
that fits for me and I've kind of
finally got to that point where I know
how to train hard to.
I don't overtrain to where I know I'm in
shape to where I know a mental.
All that stuff was kind of starting to
really combine well based on what I feel
and based on how I have lived my life
and how I've competed in how I've put my
body in stress,
so I'm able to kind of get a good
understanding of where I'm at.
When your dad went to Brazil,
was he,
was he teaching in Brazil?
My parents got split up and then my dad
went to Brazil to go recharge his
battery just to hang out.
Yeah,
to go.
He just his.
His analogy is,
his explanation is,
you know,
you put a coconut tree in America.
It doesn't grow,
Cook and you put a cup in Brazil in
coconut grove.
I cannot explain why,
so he was just to make some coconuts.
So I think he just wanted to feel good
and kind of be his on his little retreat
and it worked well and now he just moved
back actually a couple months ago.
He's moved back here and now he's kind
of after eight years of living in
Brazil,
he's kind of got more motivation to be
here in America and be a part of my
life.
And I mean,
he's always been a part of my life,
just,
I just don't,
it's not like my dad didn't help me,
but he helped me up until I was like 18,
gave me everything he could and then he
let me be my own man.
You know,
he,
he let me do everything on my own,
make my own decisions.
If I wanted to do this,
I could do it if I wanted to do that,
if I wanted to wake up at 3:00
in the afternoon I was going,
I was my own man and had the freedom to
do everything.
So he gave me the option to do whatever
I wanted and think,
God,
I was able to really embrace that and
use it to my benefit and it'd be able to
do what I did with that kind of on my
own.
You know.
Does your dad still train?
Um,
my dad teaches when he doesn't train so
much where he actually goes and tries to
get better.
He's a,
he's kind of physically can't do it
because he's got like 800 years in his
back.
He looks like a,
you know,
he,
his,
he's physically burn out,
you know,
you,
you train at the highest level for her
whole life with no.
When you say Hernias,
you mean herniated disc?
Herniated,
herniated discs.
Yes.
So it's got his back's a mess.
Oh yeah,
he,
his doctor said he shouldn't be walking,
but he walks so he can't train as much,
but he does put a gear on and he'll show
move here and there and he'll do what he
has to do.
And um,
and I think he's happy with it.
I think he's now he's gotten to a place
where,
where he is okay with being retired and
he's okay with not being the frontline
and he's okay with,
with being at the stage where,
where he is,
you know,
he knew that the time that he had to be
physically,
it was up into this age and you know,
I guess when you start to,
to fall out of your physical shape,
you want to fight it and you want to
know I can still do it.
I could.
And I think now he's very happy being
the icon that he is in being,
you know,
he helps me with what he can help.
He trains with what he can do and he's
still the man like w when he comes with
me with theories and,
and,
and training stuff.
I mean,
man,
it's like nobody else has the mind that
he has.
Even if you put his brain on anybody's
body,
there will be a champion for sure
because he has a,
an old.
He's a very great sense of how do I
adapt to anything.
So sometimes I'll come up with a move or
I'll be like,
dad,
this has been giving me problems.
And even if him not training for 10
years,
he'll still feel how to defend it or
feel how to deal with that or to have a
greater understanding of how to be.
So I think he's just better now this
time of his life,
he's incorporating different things.
He's not focused on training hard that
time for him.
It's past the time for him to fight his
past.
Now it's time for him to watch me fight.
Now it's time for him to watch himself,
you know,
teach or watching,
being an icon,
you know,
start,
what does he do for exercises?
Oh,
he serves and he and he doesn't exercise
and he'll do his little workouts and
stuff and he's still,
he's still very active but he's just not
going to go and train rounds after
rounds.
But he's definitely very healthy and
physical.
A person and I mean if I have eight
hurting your despite his age and I'm
able to do what he did,
I'll take that.
No problem.
I'll take the eight and he has to be in
the best in the world.
Note any day of the week.
So.
Well they uh,
they can do a lot for those things now.
Yeah,
I mean he's going to doctors and if you
have any,
any advice?
He definitely certainly do.
The,
uh,
Regina King that I had done was because
of a bulging disc and made a huge impact
on me.
And it's also the same thing that a lot
of football players have done.
Like Peyton manning had done on his neck
and he had two operations on his neck,
was ready to retire,
went to Germany,
had the blood spinning procedure done,
and now I was playing football than
ever.
That's great.
Massive a antiinflammatory properties of
it.
And the good thing about it is it's
using your own blood so it's not like
you're introducing a steroid or any
unnatural a substance into your body
that's going to cause an adverse side
effects.
It's actually actually your own blood.
It's amazing to see with his body how
it's been,
how well he lives in,
how he's happy to.
He says,
if I can serve and I can do the things,
if I can train once a week and do the
little moves here,
I'm okay with that.
So I don't know how far he's trying to
step into actually being feeling like 20
years old again,
but I'm sure he'd be interested to hear
what you have to say.
Well,
just pain relief and just the,
uh,
the uh,
replenishing of his body's ability to
move correctly.
It would be a huge impact.
Um,
I know a lot of guys that
are getting towards his age though that
have done Jujitsu for a long time,
have similar issues.
Ricardo Laborio told me he has seven,
seven desks,
you know,
and you know,
like standing next to Ricardo he's Kinda
like hunched over and leaned down and
when we were describing it,
you know,
you could see like he has like a
winston,
his face,
he's just thinking about the pain,
but still trains still goes out there
every now and then roles and just loves
it and can't help it.
That's the problem is Jujitsu,
so fun.
It's too bad.
Your body's not indestructable to patty.
Can't tap out,
but your bodies,
you know,
rubber indestructable.
He created like that for a reason.
I bet.
Yeah.
My Dad was still be mopping floors have,
I'd be like,
this is my time now.
They give me a break.
What was the last time your dad like
really seriously rolled?
How long ago was it?
Uh,
I dunno.
All I know is the last time we seriously
rolled.
I got fucked up.
This is bad because I just got my black
belt and I was like,
all right dad,
you know,
at this time he was still kind of not.
I mean he's had hernia disk for a long
time.
I,
he probably had her $800 disc when he
was fighting.
Really know.
Yeah,
he,
he's probably had it for a long time.
It's not just dealt with the pain.
Yeah.
He's dealt with pain his whole life.
And um,
I don't know exactly what,
what is,
what the exact he has or doesn't have.
But um,
yeah,
like when I was 21 years old,
19,
I just got my black belt and I was like,
all right dad,
let's go.
Since you're out of shape,
let give me three minutes,
three minutes and we'll go as hard as we
can for three minutes and let's see.
Because after three minutes then of
course I'm in better shape and you are
not training so much.
So I don't want that to be an issue.
And uh,
when we train man,
he got me in like a minute and a half
and I was so pissed.
Come in with a foot lock and I was like,
yeah,
all right.
He's still the man
that was the last
family we really rolled.
So,
um,
yeah,
I mean he's a,
he's a very.
I mean he's just a real Samurai.
You mean you didn't know where they put
it?
He's just all around.
It's not an act,
you know,
he's definitely in his bones.
He's ready to die today.
If something happened,
you'd be ready to die for what he
believes in.
And I think that's why I,
I believe in what he says and I believe
in what I do and why I do what I do with
so much passion.
Yeah.
He's the real deal.
And for folks who you want to get a
sense of it immediately,
even if you're not a martial artists,
the movie choke,
go watch the movie choke because that's,
you know,
Hixon when he was,
I mean essentially not quite as prime
because he was in his late thirties at
the time.
It was probably,
it was better when he was even younger
than that.
But you get a chance to see the physical
preparation when he's sitting up to his
neck in an ice glacial river and
meditating.
I mean fucking freezing cold water and
he's just breathing and concentrating.
Ace Hoyle,
he gets in,
he gets his foot and he's like,
fuck this.
Everybody else is like touching the
water and go,
oh,
this is crazy.
Your Dad's in there up to his head.
Like,
like,
it's nothing like he's in the Jacuzzi.
So yeah,
I'm.
That inspires me,
you know,
and I.
Well I remember him getting out,
you know,
happy and praising and thank you.
My Lord are loving it.
The know he embraces the challenge of it
and the braces.
Just the wildness of being in a,
in a glacier river and Japan and the
whole deal,
man.
Yeah,
he really does it.
Now.
You are starting to,
you're doing a lot of training with.
I know Gilbert Melendez,
he's a good friend of yours who
thankfully just got reassigned to a new
deal where he's going to compete against
Anthony Pettis,
who's the lightweight champion.
They're gonna fight after they coach the
ultimate fighter together,
which is a huge thing.
Um,
and you're training with a lot of the
other oil or get out outta you.
Had enough ever folks who don't know,
you know,
toilet Gracie,
so one of the greatest submission
artists of all time to and very,
very successful in competition.
So you know,
when you see the difference between how
a Hixon deals with it and how heuler
deals,
but that's when you really get a sense
of what a special person he has.
And by the way,
no one's telling him to do this.
This is all his idea in your mom's
calling.
Oh fuck.
Yeah.
And my dad never had it
coach either,
you know,
he never really had nobody there all the
time.
Time.
So that gave me more motivation to.
And also it gave him the confidence that
he could let me be on my own and,
and I was still going to be all right if
I was trying to be all right.
Now what I was going to say is you,
you've done quite a bit of training with
Nick and Nick Diaz and Ronda Rousey.
Did you do some training with her as
well?
I've never trained with Rhonda actually.
Yeah.
Um,
I've trained with Nick and nate a lot
and Gilbert and jake quite a lot,
you know,
so those guys are a big part of my
training and I've helped him out all out
with fights and
Rhonda trends with those guys on a
fairly regular basis.
Right.
She's trained with them a few times.
She definitely was up there more before,
I think.
I don't know how much she goes up there
now.
But are you planning on fighting and MMA
now?
Yeah,
I am.
So I actually,
after the ADCC I kind of,
I'm kind of starting to focus more on
mma,
kind of want my energy to be driven
towards fighting professionally and in
man.
Yeah.
That's where my energy is going these
days.
And what motivates you to want to do
that?
Like I said before,
this has been my.
I knew I was going to get to this point
when I was a little kid.
I never saw Jujitsu is my final mission
and um,
I was just waiting for a right time and
reading for myself to be ready for
whatever obstacles I can get to on this
specific situation.
So now I feel mentally ready and now I
feel the motivation and now if you would
ask me when I was 20 years old,
if I was ready to fire me,
I,
I wasn't mentally,
not physically,
not technically,
but just mentally ready to do something
like that.
So the last thing I wanted was to be
traumatized.
And uh,
now I feel like no matter what happens,
I'm ready to,
to,
to embrace whatever it happens and I'm
ready to fight.
So negotiating scene with the best
situation for me to,
to take advantage of this moment.
Now,
how have you adjusted your training to
prepare for mixed martial arts?
Some minor,
some minor adjustments.
Nothing too crazy,
but I think of course you go.
There's different obstacles and
different things that you got to worry
about when you're just dealing with
rigid soon when you're just dealing with
mma,
you know,
of course you can hit and stuff,
but I think generally my fights,
the way I fight is,
is more of a fight and I,
I kind of,
not a sport,
I'm not trying to be sporty with my
Jujitsu,
so I don't think the transfer over will
be that big of a jump as it could be for
some other guys.
People who more points oriented,
people who are kind of.
They want to stay in their columns.
I'm very comfortable in the,
in the storm.
So,
um,
I think that'll help me when I,
when I fight.
That's something.
One of the most important attitudes to
have in life is to embrace the storm
you're comfortable in the store and try
to figure out how to make yourself
uncomfortable all the time.
There's always time for relaxation after
that.
It's all over,
but don't avoid the storm
that's going to make you really asking.
Then you're going to see who you are
when you can deal,
how you react in those situations.
Absolutely.
Especially if you embrace it,
it becomes a part of who you are as a
human being that you do that,
that you take on those challenges.
What about striking?
What are you doing as far as striking?
I'm working on and a little bit here and
there.
Um,
you know,
don't want to give up too much of my
training.
But uh,
yeah,
I mean,
I think Jujitsu has striking,
you know,
there is,
it's just Jujitsu strikes when it's
beneficial for you.
It doesn't teach you to sit there in the
pocket and just bang out with anybody.
But if a striking is definitely a part
of Jujitsu and I think it's going to be
interesting to see what I can do,
you know,
I'm curious and I,
and I'm,
I want to,
I want to see what,
what happens,
you know,
so just like anybody else,
I'm very curious to see how much you do
digital is going to play in fighting and
how,
what's going to happen?
Is the Jujitsu going to be enough or is
he going to have to do this certain type
of training?
So I think,
uh,
my training with nick,
nate and,
and Jake and Gilbert is sufficient to,
to really put me wherever I want to be.
Now your,
your,
um,
your uncle who is said recently,
you know,
that you don't need anything other than
introducer.
Is it all these different people that
the train wrestling and all these
different aspects of striking that you
really don't need it just trained
Jujitsu.
Do you,
do you agree with that or do you think
that in modern mixed martial arts it is
important that you cross train?
It is important that you prepare for
full mixed martial arts competition or
do you think that the highest level of
Jujitsu is still sufficient fish
it,
I think Jujitsu is sufficient.
I think it's sufficient to be the best
martial arts.
I just think that rule is make it so
that it's not necessarily possible.
So the rounds,
the gloves,
the rules,
you know,
those things all change the sport and it
changes the situation.
Standups,
yeah.
Like if you have no gloves,
nobody's going to be throwing those
punches that guys throw these days.
So you're going to break your hand first
punch,
you throw the guy,
ducks his head,
you're going to break your hands.
So I think that all those things change
it and when it changes,
you have to be ready to adapt to what
changes personally.
If you put two guys in a cage in Jujitsu
is enough,
but when you put on the gloves and you
put the time and you put the rounds and
you put the,
you know,
all these things,
the steroids,
so it changes the situation and,
and you know,
guys are more willing to just throw the
hardest punches and knock you out
because they know that the round is
going to end because they know that
their hands not necessarily going to
break.
So if you asked me what's the best
martial arts,
I think judy who?
Of course,
if you ask me what is digital enough?
Yes.
It just depends on the rules.
If you tell me,
okay,
it's a two minute round and the guy is
gonna stand you up,
or do you know?
Of course then you have to learn how to
box.
You have to learn how to do this,
and personally I'm deflection of punches
is always been a part of Jew to be not
necessarily being able to strike.
I don't know necessarily if I'm gonna be
knocking guys out,
but I'm going to be able to defend my
goal into the Jujitsu.
Go in.
The principle is to be able to defend
whatever the guy's gonna do.
If the guy's going to punch you,
you have to be able to defend the punch.
You have to be so I don't necessarily
think that you have to be a great
striker to to win mma and to be a champ,
but you have to be able to defend
yourself.
You have to be able to know where the
punch is coming from.
You have to be able to know what's going
on.
You have to know about stuff.
It's not like,
oh,
Guy Trained Jujitsu for 20 years and
then he goes into a fight.
He's going to get,
he's going to get beat up,
you know,
so it depends how you train and what
your worry is and how well you adapt to
whatever's going on in the fight.
Your Dad always said that,
that he doesn't train kickboxing to
become a kickboxer transit to know what
they're doing.
Yes,
exactly.
So I feel comfortable.
So who were you talking to?
Are you talking to organizations?
Can you tell me?
Uh,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm talking to right now.
I'm negotiating with Japan.
Nothing's for sure,
but it's looking good and I'm trying to
see if I can get a,
there's an opportunity for me in Japan.
So what organizations are left in Japan
right now?
Don't,
can't really say too much right now,
but basically it's very shortly we'll,
we'll know going
on with that.
And uh,
well for folks who don't know,
your,
your dad was a huge star in Japan.
Yeah,
they had a comic book based on them.
I mean there was a lot of fanfare and
publicity and they,
they embraced him,
especially when he won the Japan valley.
Tudos,
I mean,
your dad was an enormous star over there
and I think that,
that sense that you would want to
compete over there because they would be
very interested to see.
Yeah,
there's a lot of benefits for me
starting off in Japan and,
and uh,
you know,
the just a lot better for me at this
moment in my career to start off in
Japan into,
to really build myself the best I can.
And I personally like fighting in front
of Japanese culture because,
you know,
they're,
they're a little bit more martial
artists.
They come from like a Samurai
background,
so they really care about what you are,
they really care about what you stand
for,
they really care about,
um,
if you sweep somebody in the middle of a
tournament,
they're going to clap,
you know.
So personally for me,
I,
I appreciate that and I liked that about
Japan and um,
I think it's just a time in my life and
of course,
if Japan were to ever like,
you know,
have a movement of,
of,
of being able to bring mma back to
Japan.
I think a possibility will be with
bringing me to it because that's gonna.
It's of replicate what my dad did.
You know,
how he brought it to Japan.
So I think it's,
for me in this situation,
it's,
it's a great opportunity and I'm trying
to go for that.
Yeah.
For people who don't know,
your dad was the star of pride one.
I mean that's what got pride kicked off.
That was the,
uh,
the big launching pad after he had won
the Japan Valley Tudo.
And then of course pride came close to
me.
It was an enormous event in Japan,
like they had put on 90,000
seat shows several times
60,000
Tokyo dome sold out huge.
And somehow or another it stopped.
It's one of the great mysteries of
martial arts and I don't totally
understand Japanese culture.
I guess they get really into things
sometimes and then the things fade away.
But uh,
when we were there and we did the UFC
there a couple of years ago,
it was my first time in Japan and I was
amazed that the audiences,
they were awesome.
They are amazing.
Like when the fights going on,
they're so polite and then when
something happens like a transition or
sweep,
everybody applauds.
Like it's like,
wow,
there's like,
it's really cool.
It's like I,
I really appreciate how much they love
the,
the technique and the martial arts
aspect of it.
But as far as like a crazy crowd,
there's nothing like Brazil.
There is nothing like Brazil.
This last event when Machida fought most
saucy,
I watched it at home.
And uh,
when,
when Bruce Buffer says it's time to
whole audience does it with them.
I mean there's like 18,000
people.
No one cheers.
Like a Brazilian crowd.
And they're there at the very first
fight.
That place is packed,
packed.
They're getting their money's worth.
Fuck.
Yeah.
Fucking fired up,
man.
We got there early and there was already
just a giant line around the block to
the arena.
And then when we got in it,
man,
the energy in the air was it,
it was a huge,
huge,
huge thing.
That was the last one that I was at in
Rio.
But um,
there's no crowds like Brazilian crowds.
The Japanese soccer,
they come from the soccer backgrounds,
so they're really into that.
Japanese crowds are just different in
their own way.
Completely different.
Very,
very different from the Brazilian
crowds,
but different in their own unique way.
So does.
Is there a timeline on when this is
going to happen?
Basically we're going to know very soon,
very,
very soon in the next.
Probably the next time I see you.
It will be you.
I'll have an answer and so I'm just
waiting.
I don't want to give up a date or a
time.
I don't want to put too much energy
into,
into that because I hope it happens so
much that I don't want to spoil
anything.
So see.
And it's going to happen very soon.
So I'll let you know.
I'll let you know.
Don't worry,
be able to.
Did you watch the UFC this weekend?
I did not.
I just missed it.
Damian Maya,
who is a very excellent representative
of Jujitsu,
fought Rory Macdonald and got beat up.
Who,
what happened in the fight?
Well,
Damien took them down the first round of
mounted him,
but uh,
he couldn't submit them.
And Rory defended,
got back up to his feet and then started
kicking the shit out really.
And was Damien just trying to
stand up with him?
Yeah,
yeah.
Well there you go.
I mean,
I like Damien.
Damien is a,
a good guy,
you know,
and he's like,
uh,
I've always had respect for him and
we've always had a good time
relationship.
Um,
and he's always been a representative of
Jujitsu in a great way.
Um,
so I think the more he,
he focuses on that and the more he tries
to really use the J to,
the better he's going to be because he's
a specialist in Jujitsu.
He's not a specialist in striking.
So it's tough to,
to try to be an excellent person in a
different sport.
I think he should try to focus in on,
on,
on being the greatest Jujitsu fighter
and an iron man.
I think that'll be beneficial for him.
Well,
he was trying to do that.
I mean he was trying down but he
couldn't take them down.
So then they're getting his take down
stuffed.
And then he was forced to stand with
them and rory kept kicking him.
He was just kicking the shit out of him.
That's why I'm curious,
you know,
I'm curious to see for myself how it is,
fighting with guys who don't want to go
to the ground and see how I'm going to
be able to deal with it and I don't
know.
I have zero experience in mma so I'm
curious.
I'm curious to see what happens and I'm
curious to see how really difficult it
can be and where my,
where my technique is going to play a
role in how it's going to be because you
never know.
That's why I'm,
I'm really open for the,
for the challenge.
And you know,
my,
my blessings for,
for Damien,
hopefully he can find a great tactic to
beat his opponents and be guys who are
trying to do that.
Do you look at him as sort of A.
I mean he's a very high level Jujitsu
God,
you look at him and as,
as an example of what can be possible
and not the pitfalls and the
possibilities.
Yeah,
I mean I think if somebody can defend
his takedowns to something,
then there's definitely a technical
reason why that's happening.
And I think that like personally I
admire the guy,
the guy's a,
an exceptional athlete and he's a great
fighter and hear everything,
but I don't look up to his Jujitsu.
I don't look up to anybody that you did
to that is fighting these days,
you know,
I don't like seeing anything that,
that is exceptional,
you know,
I see guys that are good,
tough and guys who make it happen.
But I'm impressed with my dad's Jujitsu.
That's where I feel like I'm going to
try to replicate.
So as much as I'm a,
I'm a fan and admired and all these guys
are,
they made,
they got to where they got with the
tools that they were given,
you know,
we are all given certain amount of tools
and how will you use them?
So I can't take anything away from the
guys who got far with the Jujitsu
striking or with whatever.
But um,
yeah,
it's definitely like you're going to be
able to see,
you know,
who do you think is the best
representative of Jujitsu right now in
mixed martial arts?
Uh,
I mean,
there's a lot,
a lot of good guys,
you know,
there's,
the classics,
you know,
like,
Damien's very good.
You know,
Jack is very good.
Those guys are guys who,
I have friends with,
guys who have been competing in
tournaments in
Sergio Mariah's to his Jujitsu.
I mean,
he hasn't gotten to that level yet.
Uh,
you know,
the,
the level of opposition yet.
But his Jujitsu has been very effective
in mma.
His,
uh,
his submissions or uh,
you know,
I actually haven't seen him fight really
in MMA,
so I don't really know too much.
But his Jujitsu and Jujitsu tournament
is,
is good.
You know,
he's a tough guy.
He has a specific type of style.
But again,
I'm not impressed with his Jujitsu,
you know,
like I'm impressed with him as a,
as a whole,
you know,
he's like,
oh,
the guy can make it happen.
He can defend.
Well,
he's an exceptional athlete.
The guy is very strong,
very explosive,
but you know,
I don't see him as an exceptional
Jujitsu fighter.
What's missing for him personally?
Yeah.
I mean,
again,
like,
I don't know.
No,
but when you say,
I mean you look at a guy who was like a
high level world champion caliber
fighter,
but you say you're not impressed with
his Jujitsu.
What is not impressive about it?
Um,
uh,
I don't know because I had never seen
him fighting MMA,
so I don't know what he's doing in mma,
but when I fight him,
I fought him once he beat my ass and
then I fought him the next time and it
was a very even match.
I thought I won that match and I got.
I felt like I got gypped.
But
did they give him an advantage?
It gave them an advantage of the last
five seconds is so squirrely for folks
who don't know.
There's weird scoring and Jujitsu.
Jujitsu is zero to zero.
One guy can get what they call an
advantage and it's very subjective.
And uh,
you know,
people I've seen fucking bench clearing
brawls because of a advantage scoring.
What I feel about impressive Jujitsu is
why am I so impressed with my dad's got
to,
is because he outsmarts me.
He technically beat me.
If somebody is stronger than me and they
pass my guard or they submit me,
I am not impressed because of that.
I think that the guy used this tool to
beat me or did whatever too.
But that doesn't mean he's a better
Jujitsu.
Doesn't technically a impressed me.
So,
um,
it's very difficult to impress me.
I come from my father.
My Dad has been technically outsmarting
me for a long time,
so it's hard for me to be impressed
with,
with Jujitsu these days and that's what
I am trying to do.
I'm trying to do that is technical and
it's way harder for you to technically
outsmart somebody then for you to just
know I'm going to get it and just take
it and the guy defends and then you just
rip right through it.
So it's a different approach to what I
believe digital is about.
And that's why I feel like I'm not
impressed as much as other people or how
they see he got that arm bar.
Yeah.
But,
but he got an arm bar because he's much
stronger than the guy.
The guy has no defense.
And so I feel like it's a mind game and
however,
well you use your chest pieces,
you know,
that's what's gonna make you the
results.
But I don't take anything away from
surgery.
Mariah's,
he's a,
he's a great fighter and he's an
exceptionally healthy,
strong person and he's able to use the
tools and he's able to use Jujitsu for
his benefit.
That doesn't mean he's not good at
Jujitsu or anything.
That just means that if you speak
specifically for Jujitsu,
is he,
is he using his strength or is he using
his technical ability to,
to beat your opponent?
And that's where I say that.
That's why I say that Mark Coleman wants
certainly share this.
That was the match that I draw with
them.
He was like four,
four.
And then,
um,
I lost on an advantage at the last
second.
You were rocking the Old School Samurai
ponytail.
Just try that out for a little bit.
Nobody told me it was really gay,
so he kept going for a little bit.
Your Dad had that back in the day,
man,
that's a tribute.
That's attributed haircut.
You'd get a pass.
You get a gay pass.
When I realized it was really,
so I kinda cut it.
But did he get in the way?
Yeah,
I just got in the way and it just kind
of wasn't really my style for.
I was for awhile.
I did.
I had to do with it and then that was
it.
I was gonna say that Mark Coleman wants
told me strength is technique,
strength,
two technique for some people and that's
for some people they.
Everybody has their,
their belief,
other people,
other digital guys.
They're like,
you know,
if the movie doesn't work then use more
strength.
You know,
if the moves don't work because you're
not using enough strength.
So I'm not.
I don't come from that theory.
I don't come from that belief and I come
from a leverage and technique
background.
So that's why I feel the way I feel.
It's not because I feel against anybody
and I'm not trying to point fingers or,
or try to say that I'm better than
anybody,
nothing like that.
I still have a lot to prove,
but if you honestly ask me if I'm
impressed with the Jujitsu I come from,
I'm picking son,
you know,
I,
I come from the best.
If I'm easily impressed,
you know,
that's not a good sign.
Who impresses you in Jujitsu today?
Um,
what really impresses me is guys who are
smaller,
being able to really defeat bigger
opponents like Marcella Garcia.
My celebration is a very,
he's definitely a great fighter.
You know,
I fought him twice and he's one guy who
technically is great,
you know,
like I have nothing to say about his
technical abilities and he's,
he's technically in the game,
you know,
he's not overpower.
He's not using his physical attributes
to beat his opponent.
So I'm impressed with that.
That's,
that's a great thing that he has.
And um,
yeah,
I mean the technical ability is where I
feel like is the line for,
for,
for greatness.
And then,
yeah,
Marcella Garcia,
he's,
he's great.
I,
I love,
I love fighting him,
you know,
that's one guy who I will fight any day
that it's great to be meshing with that
kind of talent.
So,
um,
yeah,
he's a great example and he fought,
guys were really big and right there.
I almost got him,
Marcella had him in a guillotine for,
for good minute until my forums cramped
up.
But um,
if there was a professional avenue for
Jujitsu of Jujitsu was like golf or
baseball or something like that.
It was on television all the time.
Would you be motivated at all to enter
into MMA?
Um,
yeah,
I think so too because I think it's more
of a real fight and I think it's more of
a challenge and I like challenges and I
like to,
I like to challenge and I like to see
what's going to happen.
And personally I think that Jujitsu
takes away a little bit from the full
fighting for fighting because it's
punching because there's no punching in
because there's other tools.
So the less rules you have,
the more you can actually present
yourself in and use the stuff that you
have within,
you know,
the fighting spirit and find out ways to
stay safe and in personally digits,
who most of the Jujitsu these days are
very boring matches and they're very,
you know,
point oriented and they,
they,
they kind of,
you know,
it's,
it's not as interesting to watch because
guys are not really,
they're there for the wind for the point
and um,
it's not motivating for me,
you know,
it's not motivating for me to compete in
a fight like that.
I'm motivated to,
to embark on this new journey of MMA
motivated to,
to see what happened,
to see how the fight fight goes,
what I need to do with what happens if
this happens.
And I think that's a great thing.
Now when you see guys like Jocko,
right,
who were great Jujitsu artists and now
entering into mma and just drunk arrays,
winning a lot of his fights with
kickboxing.
Yeah.
And a lot of guys that he's fighting,
he's not able to take down.
So some sort of forced to stay on this
track with them.
Would you take away anything from that?
Do you learn anything from that?
Yeah,
I'm trying to learn.
I think Jakarta is great and I really
like him a lot as a human being and as
an athlete I've been his fans and she
was before,
you know,
in Jujitsu,
he was always a kind of a real cool guy
to,
to watch and he's a warrior,
you know,
that guy has a,
has a strong spirit and he's a very
strong hearted person.
So,
so whatever he does,
he's going to be good at.
And however he does it,
he's gonna be,
he's gonna make it happen and he charged
her courage is use the tools that he was
given to to get the best results that he
can get.
I don't take anything away from him.
Darn it mean by tech.
Do you personally get something from
watching him?
Like,
dude,
you learn something from his.
His approach?
Yeah.
Me Personally,
I'm kind of trying to always analyze in
more importantly,
I'm trying to see where I fit in on
this.
You know,
I want to see if it's really,
if how I'm gonna deal with somebody
who's not letting me take them down,
how am I going to get them down,
how am I going to find the way to win
the fight?
So I think it's all in the air and we're
going to see what happens and I can't
wait to start to,
to test myself in these waters and get
these challenges and find out ways to
find out ways to win.
No,
other than Gill and Jake,
how many wrestlers?
Yeah,
as you're
working with.
I mean,
in my academy there's always been great
wrestlers and great judo guys and great
everything.
They all come in and out of my academy.
So I've wrestled with the best wrestlers
and I've wrestled with uh,
you know,
I've been in the mix with a lot of great
athletes and um,
yeah,
I mean they're,
they're,
they're a part of the training,
you know,
they come in and when I go up to train
with nate or Gilbert,
there's lot of wrestlers.
And I think that's just one more tool.
One more,
one more training session.
One different types of train,
sometimes you train just tonight you're
taking.
Now sometimes you train to take somebody
down.
Sometimes you just trained Jujitsu.
Sometimes you just train defense.
Sometimes you just train one position,
so you try to build yourself as a
complete as much as you can.
And of course my specialty will never be
wrestling.
My specialty will never be boxing or
kickboxing.
It's never going to be my specialty,
so I'm just like,
Jack,
his specialty is not going to be stand
up.
He's great at standup,
he's knocking guys out,
he's doing great,
but that's not his specialty.
When you ask him where he feels the best
is going to be Jujitsu.
So I feel like my best is always going
to be Jujitsu as much as I trained the
other stuff and as much as I feel
comfortable in the other place,
I want to bring the fight to where I'm
where I feel great.
That's why Anderson Silva was champion
for so long was because he was able to
keep the fight where he felt
comfortable.
He was able to keep the fight on his
feet and in that,
you know,
elusiveness,
he was able to win if he was like,
I don't care,
I get taken down and let the guys
mountain and do this stuff.
And then they didn't fight to get up.
Then he would have lost a long time
before.
But because he was so well at being able
to stay in his where he's comfortable at
and keep the fight where he wants to
keep it right.
He was an exceptional legend,
you know,
for,
for so long and you know,
that's something to admire.
And,
and I,
I see guys,
a lot of guys are just just general.
A lot of guys are just really good at
everything.
Nobody is a special ed specialist in
anything and suffer some here and there.
But generally mma is just,
you're just good at everything.
You're not specialized in something.
So I think for me,
coming from a martial arts background,
not coming from an MMA background,
not coming from.
I didn't just start doing this because I
saw her on TV.
I come from a tradition in my tradition
is due to my tradition,
is his technique and leverage and that's
what I based my whole life on.
So if I'm going to fight,
I'm going to use that to my benefit.
You know,
there's one pattern that we do see in
mma all the time,
is that when a guy gets truly excellent
at any one aspect of fighting,
that will always be that advantage when
it gets into the octagon that it.
It always is a significant advantage
over people that have never competed in
that individual form.
Like,
like for example,
like if you take a guy like Anderson
Silva is a total specialists to stand up
striking specialist being his whole
career as a standup striking specialists
in order for you to get that good as he
was at a whole lifetime.
It's a whole lifetime.
Yeah.
So that's.
I don't got to live
right now.
Do what I got going on.
Where's your academy?
Where?
Where do you teach?
I teach in Culver City right next to
apply to the way a Jefferson and
centinela.
It was called the chrome grace home.
Now.
Do you find that teaching makes you
better at your too?
Yeah,
I've been teaching since I was 15,
so everyday I teach even till today I
still get better and I realized
something that could be better or
realize how I can explain something
better or realize how I can see a
different side and teaching for me has
definitely been a huge part of my growth
in Jujitsu and I see people who just
trained and don't teach and I see a big
difference in the people who do cheat
and how much more knowledgeable they are
and how much better they can be from
that.
Yeah,
it's interesting,
isn't it,
that teaching someone who doesn't know
something forces you to think about
almost every single aspect of it,
including parts of it that you could
sort of take for granted and it seems to
translate not just what you do too,
but kind of any.
Anything that you teach people?
Course.
Yeah.
If sometimes you do something naturally
and it just feels right and then when
somebody asks,
oh,
how'd you do that?
Or how'd you get out?
Then you have to like sit and you have
to program your mind to do and know what
you're doing instead of just reacting.
You know,
you have to know like,
oh,
this is.
I knew I did that and I know.
So I think it's a teaching for me has
been huge and I really,
really enjoy teaching much more now.
You know,
I really enjoyed teaching.
I really enjoy making people better.
I really enjoy,
you know,
as a teacher I am able to see what a
person needs and see where,
where,
where he's weak and try to make it
better instead of coming in with a class
like in my mind,
oh,
I'm going to just teach this class,
I'm going to just teach this move.
Now I'm looking specifically to see what
this person is lacking in and how it's
going to benefit.
Some guys are too hyper,
you have to calm down,
breathe.
Some guys are too slow.
Wake up buddy.
Come on,
let's get it going.
You know?
And so I think the,
the,
the good teacher is the one who kind of
adapt to the needs of the student for
the,
for the goal of being better,
you know,
I'm not necessarily trying to make you
feel good.
believe something.
I'm trying to make you better at g two,
you have to get better,
you have to be a little bit better every
time you leave me,
you know.
So,
um,
I really believe that the more I teach
and especially for me personally because
my dad left when I was 18,
so I had all these students at the
academy,
you know,
all these were all my training partners.
So I had to teach these people to be
better so that I could have good
training because if I didn't have,
if I was,
they're like,
oh yeah,
just do that move.
Yeah,
keep going guys.
Keep going.
Open training.
All right.
But then I will not have great training
partners the way I do now.
I have great training partner now
because I was like,
okay,
how is this guy to beat me or don't let
me get to this position and I'm very
passionate on letting these guys get
better to tell him.
I'll tell him,
man,
dude,
the way you're going to pay me to do
like this and I'm making these guys
better to try to beat me so that one
they stay motivated and to.
So they gave me great training because I
can train now in my academy for four or
five.
I don't need to go to train with these
other because I have guys who know
exactly what I do and I tell them
exactly how to defend it and I'm working
that and the better I make them the
better they're gonna make me.
So.
So you were teaching at Your Dad's
academy when you were 18?
You were basically 15,
15.
I started teaching,
but I wasn't running the academy.
I wasn't teaching the classes at 16.
I taught like once a week 17.
I started teaching a couple more times a
week.
By 18 I was fully teaching everything
and running the whole academy.
Wow.
So that's what you've been doing
essentially for a living?
Yeah.
Wow,
that's crazy.
So for the past seven years that's been
what you do will.
Since I was 18,
I've been,
since I was 15,
I had been all the money I make is from
Jujitsu.
So yeah.
Wow,
that's incredible.
So now when you teach 'em how many days
a week you teaching?
I teach once a day.
Once a day,
yeah.
Do you have daytime classes?
It's someone else teaches.
I teach once a day and then some days I
teach twice and then some days I,
I the afternoon class and so I kind of
scatter it out to where I can get to
every teach two days in the afternoon
and then I'll teach every night and then
so some days on Tuesdays I teach twice a
day but.
But yeah I teach a lot and I also teach
enough to where I don't over teaching
get kind of.
Because I've taught before where I teach
every class and that's training,
you know,
you give a lot of your energy,
you teach it,
you know,
you give,
give,
give and then you have nothing for
yourself.
So I've found my kind of remedy of how
much I can teach to where I still feel
good about myself and still have enough
to do the things I need to do.
So I teach,
you know,
Monday through Thursday nights and then
I teach Tuesday and Friday mornings and
then salaries,
open training and so I kind of give
myself a time to not have those
responsibilities
now.
How do you structure a class?
Do you,
do you sit down and write out what your
objectives are for each class?
Do you structure them in on the fly?
Like as you get there,
do you have specific things that you
want to work on?
Certain drills that you think that
people are lacking in?
Like
everyday is different and it depends a
lot on my mood to a.
Some days I want to do a specific
training for me,
so I'll do like,
oh,
something that I feel like I need to
work on,
so then I'll teach that move and I'll
have something I know I'm not the
greatest asset,
so I'll teach that move and didn't try
to really research and see how I can
make it better and then work on that
move.
Sometimes I see what the class needs and
what,
what the,
what.
I feel like those people who are in that
class,
how are they going to get the most out
of that class?
So some days it's,
it's like that.
Some days it's not.
Some days I come up with stuff on the
moment,
some days I'm kind of like thinking
about something all day.
Everyday is different and uh,
are basically.
I never write anything down before I
kind of just do everything on the spot.
And basically my goal when I'm teaching
is to make my students better and to
make them a gain.
You know?
So how I'm going to do that,
I don't know.
I'm just going to kind of see and feel
where,
where it is,
you know,
sometimes I have a lot more beginners.
I'm not going to teach a fancy or
something that took me 20 years to
figure out.
I'm not gonna teach it to somebody
beginners,
so if there's a class in,
it's mostly beginners,
I'm going to teach him mostly beginner
stuff.
There's a class in,
it's these guys want to all train,
then we will do all these trends.
So it depends.
It's an interesting aspect about Jujitsu
that most people that have never
trained,
but it's very difficult for them to
grasp the depth of technique.
There's so many different techniques and
there's so many different techniques
that transitioned into other techniques.
It's for the lay person to kind of
understand it.
It's almost impossible.
So when you,
when you see someone like yourself that
has a deep knowledge of it and then
teaches and trains and competes,
you got to kind of pay attention to it
for many,
many,
many hours before you even see how deep
the water is.
Yeah.
I feel like the more you learn,
the more you realize you don't know,
you know,
and it can always be easier for,
like if you're training and you're
having trouble,
if it's difficult for you to beat your
opponent,
then it's,
you're doing something wrong,
you know,
it should be easy.
You should be able to outsmart your
opponent and it should be easy.
Jujitsu is easy really.
So if you're having a struggle with any
kind of training session or anything,
then that means you need to improve on
something else to make your life easier.
So I really don't think that there is
ever like a cap where you're going to be
like,
oh,
I know everything and I,
I,
it gets to such a small detail and then
it gets to like the timing of not only
being able to know and to do what you
do,
but do it at the right time.
So it's very complicated.
So complicated.
I've cried so many times trying to
figure it out.
Uh,
identity still to this day I feel like,
fuck,
I'm only like maybe even halfway of
where I want to be.
Dennis Mckenna,
who's a very brilliant guy,
an interesting expression when it came
to learning things,
he said,
the brighter the bonfire of
enlightenment,
the more surface area of ignorance is
revealed.
So the more you know,
the more you realize God,
there's so much shit to.
No,
it's true and it sort of applies to
everything,
but I think one of the unique things
about Jujitsu and one of the things that
I've gotten,
not just for myself but from other
people that I've inspired to begin
Jujitsu and start training Jujitsu,
is that they say that it makes
everything else in their life better.
That they say that the,
the Jujitsu training,
the difficulty of it and the learning
about themselves has helped them in
virtually everything they do.
Yeah,
I definitely agree.
I wouldn't.
You couldn't give me a billion dollars
today to take away the Jujitsu.
I know,
and you know,
that's it.
There's no way,
you know,
like how I feel as a man,
how I talk and how I am.
He's 100 percent because of Jujitsu and
that's just something that I'm very
grateful to be to have landed where I
landed in the footsteps of following my
father's footsteps and it's just a real
Jujitsu will for sure.
Save your ass it one way or another.
Not necessarily a physical fight,
but also being able to deal with
yourself,
know about yourself and and it really
improve yourself as a whole because it's
very easy to get trapped into like a
daily life schedule and you kind of
don't even tap to your potential.
You don't even tap into discovering
yourself and realizing all these
feelings.
I feel alive when I could compete and
when I trained for a fight and when I
know I got to fight in this deadline and
if you on this day,
you're going to show up whether you're
going to be ready or not or whether
you're sick or hurt or this day this is
going to happen.
So to know that that is going to happen
and to be nervous and to train for that
and to put so much energy and wake up
early and do a and drink this special
juice and do this and,
and you know,
eat healthy and all this stuff that only
makes you know more sure of yourself.
And when the day happens,
you know,
like then after.
So it makes me feel alive.
I,
all these feelings that you get before
you fight or when you're fighting or
training for a fight.
It makes me feel alive and I love that
feeling.
Now if you take away competition from my
life,
I will go crazy.
I'll go,
I'll go crazy.
I would just wouldn't know.
What days would you seem like?
Repetitive.
I have no passion.
I lose my drive.
I kind of just start going down a dark
hole.
So I think that Jujitsu competitions
really makes me feel alive and every
time before I feel nervous and then
after when I win or lose it,
it's just a,
you only gain.
And when you know that you're going to
have a fight,
you gained.
Because you know that you've got to be
at your best,
so you always like,
how am I going to get my better?
You're never good enough,
and then it's just so.
It makes me feel real good.
Well,
one of the things that I feel is missing
in today's society is that people can
get by really easily.
You know,
all you have to do is show up for work,
do your job,
go home,
eat food,
go to sleep.
You don't have to struggle to acquire
that food.
You don't have to really go through life
or death scenarios on a daily basis.
For most people,
a life or death scenario is incredibly,
incredibly rare,
but those scenarios are sort of
replicated inside the gym on a daily
basis.
When somebody,
some Jujitsu black belt is mounting you
and he's choking the shit out of you.
Survival is the key thing.
It's real.
Like,
you know,
look,
if,
if I'm rolling and you know John Jocks
on top of me and he's got an arm
triangle and I might black out,
I'm 100 percent certain,
he's not going to kill me.
He'll tap me,
you know,
I'll go.
Even if he chokes me up and go to sleep,
I know that I'm going to survive.
But you don't feel that at the time when
you're,
when you are getting choked,
that is life or death.
It really,
truly is.
Can't fake those feelings that you feel
when you're training and you put
yourself through all these situations.
And I've been put to sleep many times in
training,
you know,
and you know,
that's a crazy feeling.
You know,
it's a crazy feeling to like
I don't want it to have been.
I don't want.
I'm going to almost get out and I'm
going to own more than.
And then you just wake up and you mother
fuckers are laughing at.
So
that's,
that's feeling
that you cannot replace.
There is no other way that you're going
to be able to feel that unless you
personally are like living in that
moment and no matter what,
there's nothing more intense than
somebody trying to choke you.
You know,
your natural,
so you,
you feel those feelings and,
and how you deal with those feelings are
going to really dedicate your life.
And that's how I kind of am able to read
people,
is how they deal.
How do they deal when they're under
stress?
How do they deal when they're winning?
How are they deal when their.
Everything's going good?
Are they the same person when they're
losing them,
when they're winning?
How do they deal with when somebody out
tomorrow?
So I've kind of always been really
curious to see how people are and how
they,
how do they react,
you know,
how are you going to react when somebody
beating you,
how you interact with somebody who's,
when you're,
when you're winning,
when,
when you're stronger or how are going to
rack when somebody is weaker and you're
just trying to help.
So I think it's a kind of a great,
um,
experience.
Jujitsu reveals character.
Oh,
I have no more about my students,
didn't they know about themselves,
you know,
I will tell them exactly where they,
uh,
you know,
I know everything about them because
I've trained with them and I know what
they feel,
how they feel,
when they're feeling great,
how they feel when they're feeling weak,
when they,
when they're winning,
you know,
I know how to feel if you're a coward or
if you're,
if you have hard,
if you've patients,
if you have dignity,
all of these things are,
are things that I can feel when I train
with you.
Just give me five,
10 minutes to train with you and I don't
know more about you than probably you
yourself,
unless you're very experienced person
who is yourself.
So,
um,
and that's what I kind of judged my
whole basis on is how I feel,
how I judge somebody on how they train.
I don't judge somebody by how they talk
to me,
you know,
sometimes I'll get people who the super
nice and they're super and super
respectful in person and they were just
the perfect person.
Right?
And then when they train,
they just the,
there's this malaise from them.
It's weird,
you know,
you're like,
Whoa,
that malice is for real
malice towards other people or
just not how they were when they were
normal,
you know.
So when they're able to act,
they're able to put this show on for
whoever,
but when they're training,
there's no way you can hide your
personality.
So.
And it goes the other way too.
It goes other people,
sometimes people are very cold and rude
and,
and that's not necessarily them,
they just don't feel necessarily when
they train their,
they're respectful and they and they,
you know,
they're trying to get better.
So there's a lot of different ways that
you can kind of feel people out.
And I just kind of do my judgment on
their training.
I don't really care what people.
Of course I care,
but I don't judge too much on what you
say and how you are.
Of course I feel it,
but when I train with you,
I'll make my final decision.
And on that note,
that's a beautiful way to describe it.
I love that.
I love that statement.
When I train with you,
I'll make my final decision.
That's so true,
man.
That's so true.
You learn so much about someone when
they train.
Now,
as far as your goals,
you've achieved world championship
status in Jujitsu.
What are your goals from now?
Uh,
my goal now is to focus on MMA and,
and to be the best I can be in mma.
So that's my new mission.
And so you have aspirations to fight in
the UFC?
Yeah,
I mean right now I think the Japan is
the bed is the better opportunity for
me,
but you know,
whatever,
if it's UFC or you know,
I'd love to fight in the UFC has the
best fighters in the best organization.
So of course I would like to test myself
against those guys.
So you want to try other organizations
first,
get your feet wet and mma and then
eventually jump in.
I don't know exactly,
but all I know is right now I have Japan
to negotiate with and I know that of
course wherever the best fighters are,
that's where all want to be.
What do you,
what do you think about guys like,
like [inaudible] grace here,
for example,
he's a perfect example of a guy's,
a very high level Jujitsu guy who just
hasn't really been able to get that much
going in mma.
Um,
I don't train with him so I don't really
know.
Uh,
I know that he's a legend in Jujitsu and
he's been able to really excel energy
to,
um,
but I don't train with him.
I don't know necessarily how well he,
what he does or anything.
So,
uh,
I really hope that he's able to excel in
mma and I really hope that he's able to,
um,
show what he's about and bringing the
game to his game.
And I saw a fight with him with the
Kennedy,
I think it was and I just felt like he
wasn't able to find his place and he
wasn't able to find,
um,
find himself in the fight.
And I don't know if that's lack of
training,
lack of advice,
lack of knowing what to do.
I don't know what it is really.
And I'm curious to see if that's going
to happen with me too,
because it gets also Tim Kennedy to Tim.
Kenny Kenny's really good verizon
animal.
Very good.
But
he's really a dangerous guy,
you know,
a lot of stuff.
Way cuts and this,
that's how they start to.
So there's no real,
I don't know,
and I'm not the owner of the truth to be
able to tell you what he's doing or why
he's not or what.
I Dunno.
He's different than me.
He's a different sides of me.
He's a huge guy.
Um,
I would love to see him just whoop ass,
you know,
I would love to see them do really well,
but his thought was a little different
than mine.
You know,
he is bigger.
He,
I'm not.
I have to 100 rely 100 percent rely on
my technique and my leverage.
And,
and uh,
we'll see what happens.
I'm really curious.
That's why I'm in this is to see and to
prove to the people what I'm about.
So I hope harsher winds and I hope he
does well and I'm hoping he's able to
find himself and really be able to be
where he's at,
which is the number one place,
you know,
that's where he deserves to be.
Were you there for any of horrors,
MMA fights?
No.
He,
um,
he had some disastrous,
disastrous results in MMA.
Get some really high level guys were,
it seems like maybe he took some fights
that maybe wasn't quite prepared for.
Um,
do you learn from anything like that
when you see him fighting?
Guys like he fucked kid Yamamoto.
Right?
And kinky,
pseudo and real,
real high level guys.
Yeah.
I don't know,
I,
I just,
uh,
but he's another example of a very
technical Jujitsu guy.
Very high level.
I'm curious,
you know,
I'm curious to see.
I'm going to be about in mma really for
me to say sit here and tell you and be
and act like I know what I'm doing and
like I know the rules and I like,
I know that the truth behind everything
is bullshit because I don't.
And I'm in it just like you're curious
to see how I'm going to do.
I'm curious to see how I'm going to do
too and I hope I do well and I hope I am
able to,
to,
to do everything that I want to do,
but I don't know.
I don't know if that's going to happen
and that's why we're going to.
That's why I go there and test myself
because if I knew I was going to win,
I probably wouldn't even fight.
Well,
that's a beautiful aspect of what you're
trying to do.
The fact that you embracing a challenge
that you are,
you are gravitating towards the most
difficult thing you could possibly do.
And I can't to see what you're saying.
You know,
it's beautiful.
The attitudes,
beautiful.
Your,
your,
your thought process behind it,
the reason why you're doing it in the
first place.
It's all,
all the right stuff and all that stuff.
Thank you.
Well listen,
man,
thank you very much for an awesome
conversation and I look forward to
seeing you compete in whatever you do,
whether it's Jujitsu or mma.
I love your attitude.
I love all the things you've said.
I think you've opened up a lot of
people's ideas and a lot of people's
minds on how profound you're thinking
is.
And uh,
I think,
uh,
it's very inspirational.
I appreciate it.
Enjoyed it very,
very much.
Thank you.
So if you are anywhere near Culver City,
that's where your,
your academy is,
what?
Give us the address and what's the.
Do you have a website for the academy?
Kron Gracie Jujitsu.com.
And My instagram is real kid
instagram,
Rio kid kron Gracie Jujitsu.com.
Go there folks.
Learn.
Train some series legacy here and
hopefully we'll see you in a,
in mma.
I would love to call one of your fights
in the UFC.
There will be an honor for me to imagine
a beautiful podcast is done.
Ladies and Gentlemen,
uh,
thank you to our sponsors.
Thanks to squarespace.
Go to squarespace.com
and use the code word Joe to save 10
percent off.
Go to [inaudible] dot com.
Use the code word Rogan.
Save 10 percent off any and all
supplements will be back tomorrow with
David Seaman and we will be back on
Thursday with Brian counts.
Steve Rinella and Doug during.
We're going to talk about a hunting trip
in Wisconsin and share some hilarious
stories and we've got a lot,
a lot of good guests coming,
a lot of good shit.
So we'll see you guys soon and much
love.